peu
[Musique]
quinze ans or ces combats
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle bestion merde qui votent
la mort bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle
version estivale avec nous ce soir
longue vie
ok
10 meur en recul
david charvet gignac l'air
d'état
quant au nord
rachida brakni
ajayi
olivier giesbert
[Applaudissements]
les modestes
comme blindtest coaxial
et moi là messieurs puisqu'il est
consacré ce soir au drôle d'oiseau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'un des meilleurs moments de
l'émission précédente
merci père noël
[Musique]
manille tandis hertz danse connaît
thierry vraiment ça vous embête de faire
de la promo vous qui est quand même une
des premières stars françaises à sa
maman un sommaire des rencontres et des
[ __ ] comme vous voulez mais sans
gilles je connais pas assez pour ça
bonjour à entrer dans les détails
ça se passe comment romain d'entre eux
n'ont marathon j'ai eu en fait ce qui
s'appelle un
un chagrin d'amour déjà je me suis
rendue compte qu'elle m'aimait plus
parce qu'en fait elle ne l
j'avais ma main dans la sienne elle
répondait plus à oppression que
j'exerçais sur sa main peut-être était
décédée si vous êtes une femme
est-ce que vous soyez une femme facile
je serai je serai pas une femme ultra
difficile
si vous étiez une femme est ce que vous
feriez refaire les seins si j'étais une
femme je crois que j'aurais des petits
seins avec un petit pu saquer nerveux ou
la wii et sa part s'en va alors c'est
une femme qu'est ce que vous voulez sur
la poitrine de romane bohringer si vous
étiez une femme se serait que toi votre
prénom
romane a la chance que vous avez
vraiment je sais moi quelqu'un parle
comme ça de ma fille je reviens pas ont
dit qu'ils n'avaient pas la voir avec
parmi tous les gens qui sont autour de
cette tâche quelle serait votre mari
ouais c'est vrai à boehringer quand même
mais qui bien les missions qui me
rappelle
j'ai jamais vu
et pourtant j'en ai vu
mais ce que pour devenir culte vous
serez capable de dire par exemple à
romane bohringer a one to fuck
je les ai vus mois en direct non non je
me permettre d offert mais sur laquelle
la précision qui suis fan tu cours très
vite dans ce dédale beaucoup et je vais
même te dire je crois que je vais
m'éclater en plusieurs barrages et donc
quand tu crois que tu m'as éviter la
[Applaudissements]
il a toujours la pêche un commentaire
quand j crew qui partirait jamais
[Applaudissements]
tiens
mais dites-moi florent vous avez jamais
rencontré sur un plateau de télévision
quelqu'un qui vous dit que les impôts ça
sert à payer les crèches les hôpitaux
que c'est vachement important de paie
des impôts quand on gagne du pognon bien
sûr mais moi je dis je veux les payer
moi je ne sais pas mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'on ne tombe pas d'accord sur le
dossier le prix des ronds points
parce que soyez si c'est mon argent
c'est moi qui me est-ce que pour réussir
vous soyez prêtes à porter des fringues
affreuse choisi par des stylistes décidé
que je vous dois mon goldorak et parfums
n'importe quelle page et un mac et un
mot qui après deux vaudois n'ont pas un
petit mot comme lola aussi aux non ça
serait bon non un bol en alava doit
chercher le mot qui vous plaît ok passer
du dictionnaire à thierry savy chercher
la page
91 dans le dictionnaire où l'on ne
changeait pas l'idée c'est général 8e
définition dans la colonne côté droite 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
vous les jeunes disent oui
asservissement [ __ ] c'est ça qui l'a
touché récemment tiré est ce que il m'a
vous pouvez remonter le tee shirt de
steve o pour qu'on voie le tatouage que
vous avez dans le dos il a le tatouage
le plus nul que j'ai jamais vue voilà
c'est ça gueule en juillet ça vous
inquiète pas le fait que george w bush
soit entouré d'une bande de mecs qui
veulent faire régner comme ça leur paie
sur le monde tout ce que j'ai à dire
c'est que je pense pas qu'il y ait eu
des armes de destruction massive en iraq
oil a en fait on s'en fout si on n'avait
pas ce qu'on voulait prendre ces télés
les champs pétrolifères vous voulez le
pétrole de l'irak c'est ça qui nous
intéressait super bagnols aux états unis
qu'on peut compter
[Applaudissements]
ouais
facile en ma vie
son aura
la rumba tout bon soir bonsoir alors
laurent tu sais qu'on est dans tout le
monde en parle version estivale
oui ouais si la crème de la rente à vie
manutan diverses danses connu
et on vend ses appareils il faut quand
même idée à place l'année dernière vous
aviez fait des photos d'ailleurs votre
appareil avait été vendu extrêmement
cher à bolton 1-1 y avait quoi sur ces
photos j'avais laurent taulin le film où
vous jouez que vous préférez sophie en
fait la vérité en vérité je n'aime pas
trop me voir dans les films que j'ai
faits c'est marrant moi aussi c'est bien
c'est pas tout ça
moi j'aime pas trop tôt est-ce qu'à
l'intérieur de la villa d'arthur c'était
aussi chiant que à la télé quand on le
regarde et nous a dû danser c'est autre
chose et me va s'arrêter lui c'est
pourtant
non elle est toujours et les
journalistes ils sont emprisonnés à
l'étranger c'est vrai j'ai vécu
longtemps vraiment je le dis pour les
enchères comme des tissus aimez vous et
vous même
aimez vous les uns les autres aimez-vous
réguler les uns les autres
ouais ouais à nîmes l2 j'agis première
j'ai jamais dit
j'adore l'inde parce qu'il ya plein de
petits singes et révèle faire là bas
j'aime beaucoup parce que les gens
vivent non mais c'est aujourd'hui c'est
le grand amour henri leconte avec un
grand tas absolument comment tu parles
ed rush pas quoi tu as peut-être de
groote gros ça vous aurez compris quand
vous êtes rentrée elle veut dire et
c'est ce qu'il fait lui que la tonne
c'est une star du porno c'est pour mieux
se ressourcer dans là explique paula jeu
franchement je ne sais pas j'ai une
clause de confidentialité dans mon
contrat
partout où est kadhafi n'a pas voulu via
les toits moi je peux pas moi j'ai des
blattes en son nom pendant que tu as
quoi jeu des blacks
on vous dit c'est la plus belle semaine
de ma vie
c'est dans le contrat ça ou c'est
simplement sur le prompteur pendant cinq
six jours j'étais vraiment décalé s'il
formidable ce journal mais non c'est pas
eux qui sont formidables c'est le fait
d'être séparé de tous les trucs chiants
genre portable préventive aussi sans
déconner
le deuxième single du nouvel album
d'ophélie tout le monde le fait jean je
peux vous dire tout de suite c'est la
masturbation dont il s'agit l'eau n'a ni
de regard a changé en deux ans et de
réseaux nouvelle brand lauzun jamais
eh bien dansez parfait il extrême pudeur
et mes propos ouais c'est ça ça me donne
trois fois cette touche un peu la merde
t'as vu
est-ce que vous masturber beaucoup
c'était sûr qu'il avait une balle en
attend j'avais décidé de manière
raisonnable manière raisonnable ça vous
arrive quand même et il le fait avec
vous comme mais oui on se marie bien sûr
laurent
je me débats
je me touchent même pas c'est génial ce
que vous faites pour la croix rouge
c'est avec plaisir vraiment à tout ce
qui me demandent la croix rouge je suis
prête à faire le bouche à bouche est
tout ouïe des raisons sanitaires
évidemment bien sûr c'est bien savoir ce
patronyme et poésie pour animer la
personne on met pas la langue dans quel
hôtel à paris et you like sexe cole mai
et alors là vous êtes tout seul voilà
quelques mois
si je sens bien que tu es chaude je te
croire qu est ce qu elle a fait tomber
alors son stérilet laurent baffie vous
allez remplacer sébastien grosjean dont
quatre pattes la chance de prendre la
place de laurent baffie toi tu fais
laurent baffie et l'europe et sébastien
grosjean
c'est un jet drôle cette émission voilà
est-ce que vous serez vraiment à roland
garros lundi marc ribot jane à la cuisse
je serai là sur le court lundi à nos
bons soit pas là bien alors quelques
buts en plus quand ça en plus
oui aller à payer les avions
elle attend
chara d'un viol
voici charlotte de turckheim
bonsoir madame monsieur km comment ça va
coûter pas mal mais bon vous semble oui
c'est bah ouais j'ai arrêté de fumer
avaient été chassés mauvais poil mais
moi moi aussi j'ai arrêté oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai moi aussi j'ai arrêté ouais
bon bah alors il va pas y avoir des
missions ce soir parce qu'on a tous les
trois à arrêter de fumer
voilà donc on va se [ __ ] sur la gueule
il ya dix ans donc ça va ouais ya dix
ans oui ça grossit oui car dans quinze
jours charlotte heureusement la saga de
l'été de france 2 est tournée donc vous
pouvez grossir tranquillement maintenant
pendant pendant l'été alors ça s'appelle
un été de canicule ces quatre épisodes
de 90 minutes réalisé par sébastien
grall avec anthony delon le fils pas
caché de d'alain delon alors je fais le
pitch on with this way vu l'état dans
lequel vous êtes alors c'est l'histoire
de vous donc emma vous êtes patronne du
café des tilleuls à cucuron dans le
lubéron le barbecue qui auront dans l'ue
on va retomber
le fameux touche et pas juste je sais
pas quand vous allez toucher vous savez
c'est terrible donc vous êtes veulent ma
chère charlotte vous avez un compagnon
quatre enfants dont bat antoine qui est
joué par anthony delon et alors c'est
anthony delon il rentre du brésil après
sept ans d'absence suite à un accident
alors là on rentre vraiment c'est un
truc a que des secrets dans cette série
fadil a changé de sexe mais la famille
cache un secret d'abord vous emm à vous
cacher aussi un secret si c'est très
bizarre cette histoire est très bizarre
moi j'aime bien parce que
le secret de famille est un truc qui me
passionne et et en plus on a tous une
famille d turckheim ah bon ouais un nom
de merde non c'est fait services et aux
fausses ou pas très grave si votre père
merde à gta vous l'êtes là j'ai fait la
boulette j'avais produit pas en parler
je sais mais bon je peux pas me retenir
jusqu'à la famille et la voilà bravo
c'est là donc un corbeau s'en mêle et
qu'un juge d'instruction se déchaînent
voilà et c'est parti pour quatre
épisodes de 90 minutes
c'est un petit peu entre la sphère
grégory l été meurtrier c'est ça parce
que j'aime bien aussi c'est que ça se
passe dans la bonne humeur et dire que
quand on arrive au café des tilleuls
monde va bien tourner est en pleine
forme et derrière c'est absolument de
noir des confiance les traits noirs
c'est une lutte à banon peut m'aller a
maintenant quatre fois 90 minutes par la
suite tout de suite pour l'habitant à
plein temps plein de rebondissements tu
crois que c'est ça le secret puis c'est
pas ça qui sont des habitués poste pc
mobile corbeau et puis s'était mal à
faire ville mais qu'ils cambon
vraiment dans le film moi je savais
qu'ils s'appellent pierre au bon moment
merde moi je crois que je vais passer
mes vacances en france dont pouvoir
suivre ces quatre épisodes de l'été de
ridicule manito dit serge dassault koné
tu en sois encore tous les 14 juillet
comme pour fêter un anniversaire et
parfois au coup par coup comme le jour
du mariage de thon frais je peux
entendre parler de savoir tout ça c'est
loin d'être enterré même dans les
familles et qui est de courant pour les
lettres à tes frères ta soeur marie
angèle et moi c'est tout le clan
soubeyrand quoi ça comme tu voudras et
simon il en fait toujours pas partie
les six monde hors de tout ça c'est
regarde que nous c'est des menaces en
l'air tout ça du vent le type qui les
envoient syrien c'est juste pour nous
[ __ ] la trouille voile aux riceys et
il attend son heure
et si tu vois ici et bien c'est à dire
peut-être que son heure elle est arrivée
et là ça fait beaucoup de fautes tu
crois pas oui mais on peut pas prendre
le risque sinon écoute qui avait pas y
penser
tu dis ça pour me faire plaisir mais tu
vas rester quand même je le vois dans
tes yeux têtu comme une mule la commune
mais nous comme ma mère écoutait antoine
ya personne qui a envie de se souvenir
de ce qui s'est passé cette nuit là
anthony delon et ça s'appelle un été de
canicule mesdames messieurs vous fait
une bien jolie maman il a bien de la
chance et anthony delon quand même il
essayait de bouchot elle pour faire sa
mère alors il est pas du tout quand même
à vous vous détestez le secret vous êtes
une fille franche directe
moi je me souviens la première fois que
je vous ai interviewé vous m'avez
déclaré moi j'avoue que j'étais choqué
pourtant que vous aviez fumer votre
premier pétard à l'âge de 13 ans très
jeune et que c'est la mère d'une copine
qui vous l'avez fait
ouais et gâteau d'anniversaire elle
faisait quand même les space cake ya
autre chose aussi c'est votre première
expérience homosexuelle alors là vous
m'avez raconter ça à l'époque oui vous
vous souvenez pas non mais je dit
beaucoup de conneries
j'ai été une partout sans savoir voilà
voilà ça me rendre compte j'ai avec un
bouquet de fleurs faudrait être idiot
non j'ai cru que j'arrive là-bas et je
pouvais pas imaginer en fait je suis
arrivé à la première
ouais et donc quand on arrive est la
première à une partouze on se rend pas
compte parce que c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait on se caresse quand comment
comment ça se passe arrivée à un dîner
si tu veux donc j'ai pas vu le temps
j'ai pas vu le coup venir si je peux me
permettre cette expression
voilà et puis petit à petit les gens je
trouvais avait des dépositions un petit
peu olé olé royer rhin voilà ça se
dénude un peu mais c'est elle et elle
faisait très chaud comme en ce moment
donc je me suis dit allez donc les gens
sont libres et ayant vu ses pages
bon j'avais 18 ans et avenue victor hugo
dans le 16e arrondissement et bien
moment quand j'ai vu que les gens t1
franchement à poil et que sa forte dans
tous les coins je me suis dit ça serait
pas une partouze
elle est maligne
c'était dans mon fric ne mange pas mon
truc
alors j'ai quand même un point commun
avec emma l'héroïne de la série si vous
faites toujours bonne figure tout va
bien même quand tout va mal mais vers
explain never complain c'est tout vous
ça c'est toujours comme ça votre côté
protestant aristocratique
par exemple quand vous êtes parti en
exil en espagne du parti que je vais là
bas pour des raisons personnelles
avez-vous dit à l'époque
et puis vous êtes revenu y est revenu
sans rien dire à la fin de cet exil
c'est pourtant été dur ce retour on s'en
va quelque part comme ça on brûle ses
vaisseaux et bien je sais pas je dis à
leur tour des traduire leur coin c'est
vrai parti n'était pas été pas content
papa difficile parce que tout allait mal
dans ma vie à ce moment là donc c'était
mieux de partir voilà revenir au bout de
trois ans c'était compliqué
non dsk fait trois ans en espagne
qu'est ce que j'ai fait mais j'ai vécu
j'ai travaillé j'ai c'est tellement
emmerdé que en fin de compte c'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de revenir
charlotte sur le plan sentimental
également vision très sexuel on veut
récente de la part de laurent toutes
classes que c'est une turckheim combat
est ce parce qu'elle est une particule
qui s'est tenu tout le monde va vous
savez les aristocrates enduristes suis
justement vous plaignez rarement
charlotte
pourtant vous déclariez encore récemment
dans la presse
mon coeur est à prendre de le seigneur
mon coeur et je crée ma jeunesse je n'ai
pas l'arabe si ça vous fait marrer
feriez bien de le prendre sans coeur je
n'ai pas l'âme d'une célibataire
disiez-vous charlotte
oui c'est vrai je suis célibataire en ce
moment j'aime pas du tout ça les mecs
n'ont depuis quand même temps quatre
mois on peut lancer un appel pour
regarder la caméra charlotte amoureux
alors que tu voulais un type de quel âge
tu peux donner une tranche d'âge entre
35 et 55 ans et laurent blanc vous
tombera tombera les centres d'intérêts
le sait les parties impossible 4 mois
donc voilà continuer d'en but c'est que
ça marche on a marié larusso attendait
seul est arrivé et marié là où ils sont
croyez bien charlotte
non mais c'est quoi le pont du diable
tiens
mais qu'ingénieur elle est toujours avec
elle et qui je travaille bien sur un mec
qui est ingénieur fabrice nord
extraordinaire on n'a plus revu à la
hausse
vous remarquez qu est-ce qui depuis
qu'on l'a mariée elle a disparu on n'a
plus jamais revu là où le sol est partie
avec lui pas de gaffe et il cherche
l'amour fou ou est ce que tu es prête à
avoir une expérience comme ça des
aventures de passage
avec des cinéastes par exemple qui
équipe qui pourrait même leur film cette
fois ci je serai prête à marier pendant
est pas ouais alors attendez c'est très
sérieux
ouais vous dites le à la caméra ça c'est
pas du tout la même chose de sympa avec
tout ce que je trouvais que je veux dire
j'ai surviré je ne vais pas non plus ou
moins trois billets qui me sert à ça à
cette émission
ah oui si vous saviez le nombre de gens
alors qu'on trouvait chaussure à leur
pied comme on dit nous mais tu vas
trouver là les emails mon arrivée j mais
elles vont arriver jusqu'à des fois tu
vas avoir bien mais c'est méchant
vous remarquez quand même que ça fait
quoi une dizaine de minutes qu'on parle
on n'a pas parlé de votre nez
contrairement à ce qui se passait les
télévisions chaque fois j'étais plutôt
bien maintenant on en parle on n'en
parle pas on n'en parle pas on parle pas
de votre lèvre supérieure donc c'est
vrai qu'il est important qu'un peu coup
on va pas de votre menton j'ai un
problème répond pas du tout pas du tout
justement non pas c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça qu'on n'en parle pas j'allais
très fat aux 7,7 écran de télé j'adore
je me delattre
qu'allez vous regarder à charlotte mais
toi que tu vois comme ça
on va vous
sherlock la psychanalyse nous a aidés à
être mieux dans votre peau
ah oui heureux oui bah ouais nan c'est
pas évident sa cible justement si si si
je me demande pourquoi vous êtes si bien
avant de contracter avec le font éclater
si elle se drogue ça joue aussi
et
et l'école supérieure de comédies
musicales vous je marchais bien oui
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'on
me dit je vais en parler de ça mais
c'est une et c'est enfin une école de
comédie musicale qui se monte à paris ce
qui n'existait pas et moi ça m'a
vachement plaisir parce que j'ai cherché
pendant des années quand j'étais jeune
je voulais m'inscrire là dedans et puis
mes filles chercher une école comme ça
et donc ce n'est plus on trouvait pas et
voilà et quand ils m'ont contacté et ses
déhanchements bien lui il a déjà monté
une école à cannes qui marche très bien
et ils ont enfin ça semblait incroyable
que paris n'est pas d'école de
comitologie quand même c'est vrai
charlotte interview mon ange
[Musique]
durkheim après vos premières expériences
enfantine aujourd'hui vous avez des
expériences homosexuelles de façon très
régulière très très très régulière et
oui les jours ah oui toujours tous les
jeux oui j'adore ça et dans les
partouzes et plus du tout coincé comme à
l'agent n'est pas parce que j'en
organise maintenant oui je sais ça chez
moi
les pétards aussi il n'y a plus du tout
de problème comme la première fois vous
saviez pas ciblé de fumer ou pas oh ben
non parce que maintenant c'est pas
pareil maintenant on en plante dans le
jardin aussi si vous voulez donc je ne
sais pas un morceau alors en espagne on
sait pas trop ce qui s'est passé alors
nous on a un petit peu bosser vous
travaillez en fait là bas dans un bar
sur les ramblas
oui sinon ces bars de nuit sur les
ramblas votre réputation vous le savez
là bas n'est plus à faire en vous
appelez lota le latin oui absolument
ça même dire un truc là-bas maintenant
le lotois à bar sur les ramblas je me
souviens plus que tu as fait l'adresse
mais c'est dans l'esprit c'est facile à
trouver
c'est dans le bas dans le bar à la volta
c'est très très connu et personne le
sait ici sa finale mais non non non non
non il ya trois ans quand même un oui ça
durait trois ans et pourtant c'était un
bar magnifique atp j'avoue plaisir
ah oui j'adorerais ça j'adore louis
positives venues d'ailleurs vous même à
t'appeler charlotte sur l'ut à l'époque
c
le mieux alors voilà une histoire en
plus un couac
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit le tenaient a été refait en fait
je n'ai pas du tout années comme ça des
parts de vie intime et parisien c'est
vrai j'avais année j'irai j'avais donné
que je trouvais ce qu'ils voient la gym
les ai pas beaucoup je sais que j'ai
fait un coup bon ça n'est pas ça n'a pas
tout à fait réussi ça n'a pas tout à
fait réussi mais finalement vous
regrettez pas d'avoir fait refaire comme
s'annonce certains journaux écoutez
non cette année je vais faire les
oreilles aussi parce que évidemment je
les trouve
mais je me demande s'il ne serait pas
mieux un peu plus comme ça vous donne
beaucoup tout ça également il ya eu
beaucoup d'histoires racontées sur vos
origines aristocratiques en fait c'est
pas vrai du tout simple et charlotte
keim
oui tu aideras schéma week-end mais
voilà arrêté cours chez svp
voilà exactement j'habite à la courneuve
final à quoi bon voila j'ai un curieux
c'est que c'est drôle parce que c'est
vrai ce que je vous dis quoi raconter
des trucs quand même le premier rôle que
joue et c'est au café de la gare
j'ai joué le marchand de fromages dont
je parle comme ça et tu t'arrêtes tu
dégages et/ou et j'étais plus jeune et
plus par année un agent qui m'a dit en
fait je voulais publicité attend le
pseudo tu t'es pris c'est absolument
génial je dis commencé à medibat
s'appelait anne charlotte de turckheim
c'est quand même c'est quand même gros
quand je pensais que c'était un pseudo
jamais
sur un peu
on est dedans
charlotte vous savez que vous êtes dans
tout le monde en parle version estivale
donc ça veut dire qu'on reçoit des
invités qui ont une actualité et pendant
l'été et puis qu'on regarde aussi ce qui
s'est passé de 2,2 mieux depuis le
depuis le mois de janvier
et justement il ya une autre aristocrate
qui est venu chez nous elle s'appelle
nadine de rothschild manutan diverses
danses connu nadine est ce que le retard
est tolérable
je pars du principe que les gens qui
arrivent à l'heure ne doivent pas
attendre celui qui n'est pas à l'heure
alors je me mets à table avec mes
invités et les gens arrivent après et
croyez moi ils n'arrivent pas deux fois
en retard et vous permettant la porte
quand même vous les laisser arriver
jeunesse arrivent et ils viennent pour
la vaisselle d'accord alors on doit
apporter quoi quand on va dîner chez les
gens en général on envoie des fleurs
jaunes est décédé mais sinon retour bien
aimé
mais quand on a mangé chez moi ça rit
souvent jean deysel en corse et les amis
aussi des amis quand c'est des amis en
n'importe quoi nadine si j'habite
monsieur a dîné rapidement la faille ils
m'envoient des fleurs c'était le
lendemain ils font déjà partie moi je
fais des aspects mais vous avez aussi le
lendemain effectivement le droit
d'envoyer des fleurs
alors faut-il manger de tout ça on est
obligées diabétiques non si vous avez un
ami dianétique la maîtresse de maison sa
forme avant pour on sait que nos belles
montagnes appelé le monde à l'hôtel y
avait forcément alors à question très
importante
est ce que la télé peut rester ridicule
encore dit c'est l'émission comme tout
le monde en une spéciale qui veut gagner
des millions
question pour un champion mais je dînais
avec vous peut-être oui ah oui oui en
tête-à-tête en tête haute on pourra
fixer au sol et non parce que je
m'ennuierais peut-être êtes-vous
aujourd'hui bruxelles bien est ce qu'on
peut faire du pied sous la table d'une
mais comment c'est même recommandé au
fumage aussi on sent des pièces est-ce
que la main baladeuse est autorisée
ouais ça n'est pas ça n'est pas comment
dirais je sais pas tout ce qui est un
peu hypocrite sous la table ce sont paul
faire c'est la nomme cette scène mais ça
vous est déjà arrivé de faire du plat
une femme en passant la main comme ce
coup là bas lui mais pas là
chez moi raconte par rapport à quoi dans
la banque rothschild aux comptes mais
oui mais oui oui oui c'est pas idiot je
voulais un découvert autorisé la lutte
voici vous payer en nature peut-être
mais j'ai claqué d'auteur
pourtant on file du ccg manière vraiment
dommage car en chine
pas mal hein c'est pas tomber dans leur
leader faire ça non je cherche mon sens
pleure mais je le trouve pas un îlot
billets chez toi ensuite noir mais je ne
mets pas non c'est un peu too much
médias non nadine c'était quoi s'était
passé bon d'accord c'est une [ __ ] la
domination
ces enfants
thibault
timerman
la demande et des cours non il ya alors
nadine est ce qu'on peut se soucier que
sont pas faussés s'est trompé
or
oui bien parce qu'on peut dire tout le
temps on aller par exemple en société
mais je suis surprise aujourd'hui par la
génération des femmes qui vous disent
ouais ouais tu dire oui bon quand vous
dites à un homme qui se réalise
est-ce que tu même si on vous demandait
ce que tu m'aimes
elle répondait je t'aime au lieu du ruy
jeu sur toute la différence a pu se
tenir c'est le bordel c'est pour ça
qu'il a hier à y penser
madame plus sérieusement l'année et
pourquoi telle année donc ça va partir
mais quand elle est là la plus grosse
gaffe qu'on puisse faire un dîner chez
toi de ne pas venir
ça c'est une belle rade si jolie aurait
pensé nous irons mais les fleurs sont
partis
j'ai commandé une couronne
quoi qu'il en soit david charvet vous
n'échapperez pas à l'interview
jean claude van damme alors david cet
ennui de pas avoir de girlfriend en ce
moment wa dondo because sometimes on my
word up je sais pas pourquoi elle
présentait pas
bien que avec un squat à gauche de cette
ue dallas donc qui arrive pas dans
avocat en fin d'année indique aux aliens
exactement que
on continue comme ça la vie david
qu'est-ce que tu look en premier chez
une girl
voilà un look en premier de first thing
les hommes on à gauche de cette wave the
eyes and which i look at me ouais les
allocataires dacca ce qui est agréable
c'est tout le monde comprend voilà c'est
quoi david le plus gros bullshit que tu
es sorti à une girl le plus grand bull
mais rld
que je suis vraiment un bon acteur dis
moi david c'est quoi qui top 7 le plus
en ce moment qu'est ce qui m'obsède de
plus ne dit pas d'avis lui dépend france
qui m'obsède pas beaucoup de chose qui
m'obsède je pense que je suis un grand
bosseur à tanger oublier à me vers le
coeur bat price to come to 2,7 et itouch
et à kick et tout ça et des deux awards
sometimes heures il l'a fait
à dix mois le 8e fait des misters dans
ta carrière big mistake guide mister
mystère is gonna stop et speak english
on va vous faire une interview mauvaises
langues
alors julien je vais vous demander
quelque chose d'encore plus difficile
que ce que vous venez de faire c'est
dire du mal des gens alors on va
commencer très facile on va commencer
avec saddam hussein j'ai bien trouvé une
saloperie à dire sur lui une saloperie
sais c'est pas difficile une avancée a
l'impression saddam hussein qui l'avait
très mauvais goût là quand j'ai vu ses
palais peut-être trop loin déjà non mais
je veux surveiller tonton langage parce
que là les gens je me lâche un peu si
cela je regarde je me lâche ce soir
alors une méchanceté vraiment sur ben
laden j'ai bien je sais que c'est un
petit peu d'ici samedi à l'épopée de ben
laden faut qu'il fasse attention là
l'air malade
savane vexé ça m'a vexé sa valve est
très bon on va faire on va me faciliter
un peu les choses une méchanceté sur
hitler lui mais j'en suis même pas j'en
dis non il méchancetés sur hitler
ça c'est pas dur alors bien à plat de
méchanceté a trouvé méchancetés sur les
quais 8 bits
oh non on ne sait pas pourquoi vous avez
connu eva braun non j'ai pas coller de
la brawn mais on a des on a des bouquins
qui nous explique effectivement il avait
des problèmes sexuels c'est pas pour
maintenant ça peut expliquer le reste
quand même temps j'essaie de vous aider
mais envie d'envahir la pologne qui rit
non non non anciennes
non mais c'est pas bien non alors il
méchancetés sur hitler basse et plus
grands bureaux de l'histoire voilà alors
maintenant augmenter un petit peu
différent et une méchanceté sur patrick
bruel
mais j'en suis sûre patrick bruel
en plus je savais que ça serait terrible
et je vois bientôt besoin
parce que je vais chanter avec lui je
vais pas trop engagé je vais médiévaux
qui maigrissent un peu voilà très bien
d'ailleurs comme si derrière ces
fragiles y aller vous prenez toujours
votre site votre fructose là à regarder
y avait une solution comme un téléfilm
en deux mois et c'est de la co fondé des
capotes
c'est pas les capotes c'est l'afrique et
pèse toujours des aliments ça fait du
bien évidemment alors on continue guy
bedos les méchancetés sur guy bedos guy
bedos moi je dirai rien parce que mon
ami 10 ans avait conseillé que mes
chansons guy bedos je préfère les
sketches de jeu que jean loup dabadie
lui écrivait que les revues de presse
d'accord ben voilà c'est à fond là mais
tu connais pas il ya là pour lui c'est
eric si l'épreuve chanter les morceaux
qui la chante on sait rien
christophe dechavanne qui est obligé de
faire le ménage dans le loft cas le le
nice people de tf1 la structure julien
un truc aussi à ce qu'est ce qui veut
dire pâques
qu'est ce que tu veux dire par il a fait
le ménage là il est à l'étape a vu
passer l'aspirateur un bond est allé
passer l'aspirateur ventes se passent
pas très bien
alors ça c'est trop méchant et loire
pardon il ya une époque où il y avait un
truc était un peu systématique c'est
qu'il aimait bien se faire faire pipi
dessus par des animaux dans une double
émission et ses méchants parce que si tu
dis qu'il fait en privé ça devient
méchant non non moi je connais pas en
privé c'est peut-être pas transiger il
faisait défaut moi je suis pas des
professionnels comme vous monsieur notre
mission on a tendance à peine méchante
hussein alors attention attention
luc ferry une méchanceté sur le ministre
de l'éducation nationale luc ferry il va
couler non pas des méchants ça oui pour
un ferry surtout libé ils ont atterri à
la dérive je n'ai plus les chinois est
riche avec luc ferry alors qu'est ce que
je pourrais dire une très grande
méchanceté méritent ils vraiment la
jolie femme qu'il a à a
à
alors ça c'est un peu jazz à ping
assurez la vous êtes des enfants
oui il ya bien d'autres morts
attends ça s'est passé en france mais
pas avec tout un tas pas de manette
violent dindar est ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est que moi je il m'arrive
de déjeuner ou de dîner avec lui assez
souvent avant j'espère qu'il prendra ça
très bien en vérité prendra ça pour
comme un hommage mais oui ça fait donc
ce que je veux dire section d'affilée
moi il ya plein d'autres à dire tu as
dit qu'on était des [ __ ] voilà qui
résume bien servi maintenant mesdames
messieurs fait le difficile a marre il
reste le plus difficile de tout projet
d'un clerc julien vous êtes prêts vous
allez me dire du mal
julien clerc de guillaume durand votre
ami du mannequin guillaume durand votre
grand ami guillaume durand je pense que
avec le bon service qui l'a au tennis il
devrait arrêter de me servir mon coup
droit qui est mon meilleur recueil est
possible d'essayer de plus chercher mon
revers cela dit même avec ça il me
battre c'est désespérant et en tant
qu'animateur savez je trouve très bon en
temps quand même hâte et les meilleurs
joueurs de tennis non
mauvais genre
un jour dans un studio vous rencontrez
marque la vraie merde il est sympa dans
la vie marquant savait tous qu'il
vendait de la drogue à des enfants comme
une loupe
il faut le savoir c'est ça le grand
public il a violé des animaux et les
yeux des britanniques et des allemands
bien partenaires de corse oui pardon oui
oui l'europe asie
il met pas mal julien clerc ajoutant
mais un bon engagement bo1 il est pas
libre et ben livre ma mère ah bon non à
ces demandes a fait remarquer
tirailleurs de temps en temps peut-être
temporaire angers le coup c'est
incroyable combien email pour l'instant
j'ai du finistère portable on sait
jamais un petit peu l'embarras
ce que vous entendez ces derniers temps
bonsoir ça ça va bah oui qu'est la pêche
comptant c'est normal attendu normes
star maintenant on est d'accord avec ce
disque en plus c'est encore mieux
je suis sûr alors vous êtes dj non c'est
ça qui est écrit sur votre passeport et
a écrit quoi que dj c'est vrai ça mais
c'est un métier reconnu
ah bah oui quand même depuis le temps
ils allaient pas marqué vendeurs
d'ecstasy non plus ils étaient obligés
de maintien de l'accord c'est vrai que
chaque fois que je passe la douane on
enfouit quand même cet article cela
donne avec une valise de 10 c'est
automatique
l'accord dit aussi c'est bizarre quand
même accueilli folio toujours encore des
bas il va arriver à temps tu t'en fais
pas là dans six mois david après le
succès de just a little more love
l'été dernier vous sortez cette année
just one day
c
[Musique]
car
david guetta versus but we just one day
qui est une reprise de heroes bien
entendu tout le monde a reconnu la
chanson comment ça s'est passé avec
bowie alors ben en fait c'était c'était
pas du tout sens censées sortir
officiellement ouais donc il ya dans le
langage des djs qu'on appelle les
bootleg on va dire qu'on se fait des mix
que pour nous parce comment on a envie
de passer des trucs que les autres ont
pas donc j'ai fait une version de heroes
qui est un morceau que j'adore pour
pouvoir la passer en soirée et je joue
dans un festival en hollande
voilà il ya cinq six mille personnes et
émeutes incroyable à réaction génial
donc à la suite de ça il ya plein de dj
qui viennent le voir en zorro mais c'est
quoi ce truc on voudrait bien avoir une
copie tout ça donc j'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser un simple de bowie bon mais
c'est pas grave je dis j'en fais pas
beaucoup j'ai en fait 500 un peu par
passion les venge en dix pirates puis
voilà et je les envoie un peu au dj
influents et il se trouve que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance puisque ça a plu à
des dj qui travaillent sur radio one qui
est la plus grosse radio en angleterre
ils se mettent à passer ça un jour j'ai
un coup de fil au studio du manager
lawyer de david bowie donc je dis juste
ce jour là je me suis fait choqué je
suppose qu'il était le problème
j'ai un peu peur et puis
on m'écoute et on a écouté avec david
bowie on aime beaucoup fait une
proposition a donc après être blanc je
me mets à être tout rouge et à faire des
bonhommes studio est en fait ils ont été
super et non seulement ils ont accepté
en sorte le disque mais il aurait pu me
dire bon ben voilà ça va être david
bowie un tout petit remix de david
guetta comme j'avais fait pour kylie
minogue par exemple est en fait
l'annoncé
c'est un grand honneur pour moi donc
d'avoir mon nom à côté de celui là je
vis contre david c'est énorme
ben ouais je suis assez fier c'est
vachement bien
thierry rolando exige le type
[Musique]
bienvenue d'état
d'autres la ligne
messieurs vous
saïbi ça je vais te dire ah justement
née justement ça se passe très bien et
visa c'est un single mais il en exclu
sur un cd qui s'appelle fuck me i'm
famous
ah oui voila je suis foutu et voilà la
rue savoie l'accueil des patients c'est
oui mais là c'est pas le mariage que tu
demandes et marie vie tu as qui font que
oui me i'm famous ou alors sur cet album
il ya martin solveig bob sinclair et
benny benassi entre autres
[Musique]
voilà alors des photos de mondino quand
même ouais il a fait stoner sérieux
ratés on dirait qu à deux visages
alors fuck me i'm famous c'est également
le nom de soirée que vous organisé
chaque année à un ibis à 1
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ibis a dit
nous parce qu'alors nous on et voilà on
y va parler des malheureux ben écoute
c'est d'abord c'est très beau on me le
dit pas la carte postale va au fait
qu'est ce que tu as à 7h du mat mais mpm
de 7 heures du soir à sept heures du
matin 24 heures sur 24 il ya des fêtes
partout qu'on veuille sortir
l'après-midi danser sur la plage d'ansé
dans les boîtes de nuit bon cecelia les
meilleurs dj qui viennent du monde
entier
il ya les line up enfin les la
programmation des meilleurs dj possible
chaque jour donc ça c'est extraordinaire
et nous on avait commencé avec des
petites soirées de 800 personnes
aujourd'hui on fait 8000 personnes puis
1000 personnes c'est des gros truc car
c'est comme un zénith 1 et soirées là
bas
vous savez que vous êtes dans tout le
monde en parle version estivale donc il
ya des invités qui ont une actualité cet
été ça fait déjà quatre fois que je les
dis à mon avis vous avez compris et puis
il ya aussi le meilleur de l'émission
depuis le mois de janvier
et là on va voir bayal et bill wyman qui
est venu j'allais faire un remix de bill
wyman un de ces jours image un coup de
chaud là enfin si mes toilettes alors on
va dire que à la question que vous posez
souvent plutôt beaters ou plutôt stone
moi c'est absolument plutôt stone didier
et
demain
[Applaudissements]
avec
m
corner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hop
hu
[Applaudissements]
soit
le temps
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bill wyman avec qui nous écoutions les
meilleurs morceaux des rolling stones
c'était leur music store univers là
messieurs
pas mal non à vingt dix cantons tous à
la suite la séquence est sérieux mais
comme d'hab gens connaissaient aucune ne
connais aucune américaine dont il ne
connaît pas non je le ferai que laisse
aucune chance aux non plus à moi je vais
découvrir ce groupe qui a bien marché me
semble-t-il
mais tu as fait quoi toi les parisiennes
et les parisiens il fait trop chaud pour
travailler se sont dit si ça c'est pas
du tout les rolling bag les rolling
stones c'est comme les beatles que tu
avais passé à l'ennemi tonnes
les beats l'art dans be il est
[Musique]
vous
et maintenant on a la poisse eric
cantona
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
ça va vous êtes bien cela oui bien eric
bonsoir vous avez déclaré récemment dans
le figaro télé je n'aime pas me montrer
à la télé et pour mon film qui sort
bientôt je n'irai pas là où je n'ai pas
envie d'aller
alors ça nous fait plaisir que vous
soyez là parce que c'est à dire que
j'avais envie de venir d'une certaine
façon c'est pas ce que je préfère
ouais ouais mais y'a vraiment des trucs
j'ai pas envie de faire je fais pas
c'est quoi les émissions de merde t'as
pas envie d'aller c'est des émissions je
suis pas méfiée beaucoup de la
télévision et les cantona surtout de la
télévision en réalité comme ils disent
vous dites si on la regarde plus de dix
minutes on va rester devant pendant une
heure
parce que ça accroche toi cc 1 mais je
trouve que nous sommes on s'habitue très
très vite haut débit connaît pareille et
que c'est un piège parce que c'est
étudié sur la psychologie des gens comme
ça et que si on reste plus de pas dix
minutes mais plus de dix secondes
on reste scotché à la fin de l'émission
se demande ce qu on a foutu
qu'est ce qu'on a appris et c'est un peu
le genre de magazine
je suis pas des trucs et voici tu tombe
dessus tu on est tous un peu voyeur camp
et finalement on apprend à rayer faut il
faut fuir ça c'est difficile
bah oui à fait moi c'est mon truc que
j'ai fait ce que l'on met d'accord avec
lui nous l'aurons bien sûr toujours
sinon on te prend encore un coup de
crampon dans ta gueule donc avec eric
moi je suis d'accord avec eric bien
alors ce soir je tiens à vous le dire
nous ne recevons pas le génie du foot
pas du tout pas du tout celui dont la
carrière a été brisée par le bulgare que
ce soit 10,9 et par jacquet s'est pas
celui-là qu'on reçoit d'eric cantona ma
carrière a été brisée par les ballons
kostadinov
oui le france bulgarie l'avait pas
partir en amérique house où j'ai une
carrière sept jours 15 ans et moins raté
quoi bon et puis jacques est aussi bon
on va pas revenir là dessus mais bon on
est on est pas là pour parler de ça on
va pas parler de mes promenades et
pourquoi vous en parler c'est sa façon
envie d'en parler oui toi non s'est
passé c'est que je dis souvent que je
vais pas m'étendre oui je pas mais qui
le rendent en effet rendre à cela peut
partir
[Applaudissements]
non ma part va pas coûter à 100 on va
parler de jacques est bon et vous a
barrel à la route
voilà du mondial à 98 on va pas on va
passer format français le couteau à quai
à chaque fois la fouta jacques et la
bave parce que bon enfin on va pas
parler de ça mais il ya quand même un
truc sérieux
non mais après rap on n'en parle plus là
mais c'est fait venir
non mais c'est vrai que jacques et moi
y'a rien qui me gêne dans l'histoire
jacques et vient à londres
non mais c'est vrai il vient vous voir
en angleterre pour pour voilà pour
discuter avec vous de cette
participation à la coupe du monde et
vous vous étiez dans une soirée que vous
arrivez avec deux heures de retard donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que même s'ils
venaient pour vous dire oui
il avait envie de vous dire oui voilà
c'est tout ce que je voulais dire je
pense pas qu'il venu pour me dire oui ça
bon alors c'est pas grave bah ouais non
mais ça ne l'est pas pour vous dire oui
ça s'est passé comme ça c'est très bien
ouais ça c'est loin tout ça obama à
ottawa vous n'êtes pas qu'on
approfondisse un peuple
ce que je comprends pas en fait vous
parle pas ou je sais pourquoi
non mais c'est vrai pourquoi jacquet a
estimé que la france serait plus forte
sans vous voilà c'est un truc j'ai
jamais compris comment on peut penser
quand on est sélectionneur de l'équipe
de france de football que l'équipe va
être plus forte sans eric cantona voilà
ça c'est un truc j'ai jamais compris moi
le mieux c'est que tu invites jacquet
mais non mais il s'exprime pas là dessus
j'ai lu son bouquin c'est là qui dit qui
est allé voir l'angleterre d'ailleurs
j'ai lu le bouquin jack et il s'exprime
pas là dessus il a jamais expliqué
pourquoi
c'est vrai j'ai pas lu ce bouquin
voulait pas lui arriver bien non c'est
vrai ils parlent de vous en pensez quoi
l'équipe de france aujourd'hui je suis
plus trop le nom à ce moment c'est fou
quand même si tu imagines ça a été
sympathique manche de grands joueurs du
monde mais moi je comprends je regardais
quand je pouvais reprendre quelque chose
ça pouvait nous servir un mouvement pour
ma carrière
ouais mais aujourd'hui j'ai regardé ça
pourquoi plaisir samedi j'ai plus de
plaisir je te rappelle le bureau n'ont
pas d'autres choix il faut avancer
bah écoutez on va vous montrer un petit
peu tout ça vous appréciera les mini
manito 10r sedan se connaît
alors les médias ils ont comme habitude
de refaire le match ils refont le match
ont revu le match
il adore ça on refait le match ouais si
eugène c'est comme un nom
et
ça va
vient alors martin sur le match on
refait le mac un jeune phénomène ch
prend l'eau je vais le garder pour mon
semblait alors alors ses agents à temps
1 2 3 des gens me prennent pour un
cinglé total pas du tout c'est une
émission extraordinaire que je ne rate
jamais sur lci la bid luis fernandez je
la regarde pas c'est vrai que le
démarrage en plus parce que je suis
mairie qu'est ce qui t'a mis pour le
tout et j avais seulement que lui 1
parce qu'ils se donnent à coeur joie
les émissions sont les laits un grand
connaisseur qui connaissent tous qu'ils
savent tout à une émission choses drôles
et c'est quand on essaie d'avoir une
conversation avec sensio là c'est de
parler un peu du jeu le football qui en
somme ce qui est plus intéressant pour
un technicien c'est d'essayer de d'avoir
une discours un langage quelque chose
qui se rapporte à ce que l'on fait ce
qu'on essaie de mettre en place un tous
les week-ends mais ça les intéresse pas
c'est eux c'est une autre recherche est
de savoir pourquoi un tel ne joue pas
pourquoi le président ne fait pas ceci
ou qui commande qui dirige et axa qui
les intéresse c'est le déballage
systématique j'adore aux jeunes un c
c'est un ami de longue date c'est bien
on va dire que nous sommes obligés de
signaler les carences de paris saint
germain ou d'autres clubs
quand il joue manon est une chose aussi
qui est très très bien chez eux c'est
que chacun de ses personnages
ils ont un club qu'ils ont à auxquels
ils sont très attachés indique
éventuellement bon dos ne fonctionne pas
alors là ne t'inquiète pas ils vont
essayer de ça va être très très court si
par exemple un marche bien on en parlé
qu'une minute si ça marche mal on va
parler pendant 15 min zahia mais sur les
autres on est un peu plus gentil non
c'est vrai que paris saint germain et
l'olympique de marseille attire
l'attention du public
on n'y peut rien donc il faut donner ce
que le public demande
on va pas parler et ils sont bons
sympathique et tout ça éternellement de
sedan 2-3 et de toutes ces équipes
éminemment sympathique et bon on est
pourtant comme et public
pourtant comme il s'y passe des choses
on les sent bien dans les airs mercredi
soir à bastia mercredi soir joué par le
césar tout de suite dès le coup d'envoi
alors que il avait ce genre il y avait
joué un petit peu contre strasbourg
c'est déjà y avait déjà repris depuis
qu'un étang c'est un choix c'est un
choix de peut-être par rapport à une
certaine animation de jeu où on a besoin
d'un garçon comme par l'eau dans
l'entrejeu est certes ses fans n'avaient
pas joué depuis le 1er décembre voix
pèseront parce que si je les fait venir
c'est qu'il ya un intérêt c'est un
garçon qui est gaucher qui peut prendre
ce côté gauche qui est intéressant
d'ailleurs ce qui peut nous apporter
beaucoup
vous regrettez pas là non pas du tout
cette vie avec mes idées et je vais y
aller au bout de leurs idées mais rae
oui quand tu es là méfie toi ça fait dix
ans que j'y suis et brossard à sa vidéo
des barons se maintient ce que je vois
c'est ronaldinho pourquoi elle est
restée si longtemps sur le banc la cuma
l'otan était entraîné à cela on essaye
il a fallu mettre en place une
préparation spécifique individuel pour
lui c'est une discussion au mondial j'ai
vu au zapping des jeunes irakiens qui
discutaient entre eux du rôle de
ronaldinho au psg ayant la chance de le
voir jouer avant parce qu'il ne fait pas
souvent jouer mais qu'est ce que c'est
cette histoire pourquoi il fait pas plus
jouer ronaldinho homogène fernandez luis
fernandez dit ceci ronaldinho est un
garçon qui n'est pas toujours tellement
sérieux qui a fait qu'il faut lâcher qui
s'est dit qu'il y avait dessus de 90 au
manque encore de de condition physique
condition physique et c'est sur ça que
je juge armor c'est sur ce que je vois
dur et que la seule chose c'est que moi
je le juge sur ce que je le vois à
l'entraînement sur le retard qu'il a et
puis je crois qu'il va redevenir qu'il
va refaire les efforts et pourrait jouer
des petits bouts de matches comme ça
progressivement et là par exemple depuis
le début du mois janvier de janvier je
crois qu'au total il a dû le faire jouer
neuf minutes un peu plus
paris saint germain il ya fernandez et
ronaldinho alors les deux stars là bien
tranquille je nous trouve un qui joue
c'est fernandez qui joue là tu n'as tu
vas pas dire que je peux pas supporter
dans la nuit parce que c'est quand même
un garçon qu'on a repris la seconde
année avec qui etc il a quand même été
au championnat du monde il était
champion du monde
suite au travail et qu'on a réussi avec
lui quand même des classes je sais
qu'ils jouent alors tu peux passer
portera au contraire on aimerait le
retrouver comme il était la saison
d'année à temps quel est l'entraîneur
qui va se priver d'un champion du monde
tu le connais toi celui-là c'est
peut-être peut-être été nombreux ces
grands numéros de la vérité
highland moins gênant j'aime ça commence
à chauffer dans l'état
voilà j'aime saccomano et luis fernandez
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
vous l'aimez bien commander un jour ça
mais que vous aimez bien mais là il y
avait deux extrêmes monsieur que j'adore
/ je déteste à saccomano non c'est pas
mon truc bien alors aujourd'hui on est
loin de ça il est content on a
aujourd'hui on parle cinéma vous avez
fait le bonheur est dans le pré
d'etienne chatiliez les enfants du
marais de becker mookie d'hervé palud et
vous venez de réaliser vous même votre
deuxième court métrage d'après une
nouvelle de charles bukowski
c'est une histoire très intéressante
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui rend
visite à sa femme qui est interné dans
un hôpital psychiatrique et elle lui
reproche de la trompait finalement
d'être la cause de son mal et lui il
s'en va comme ça il la laisse et il va
rejoindre sa maîtresse je trouve c'est
plus un truc sur la paranoïa quoi
qu'est-ce que la paranoïa je crois qu'à
un moment donné on vérifie tout ce qu'on
est
nous parlons un peu vérifier à monique
la raison en l'occurrence sur la
fidélité d'une fidélité
une femme qui est vraiment paranoïaque
se marie très fidèle à force de le
soupçonner un mec se sentant coupable
au bout d'un moment il va moi je suis
coupable donc je vais le faire d'autres
cas le vérifie cas-là réseau soit c'est
pas vrai il ya cela lui c'est un brin
fidèle et il a manipulé la remballe
aurillac complexe donc c'est un truc
autour de ça ça me donne une réponse que
c'est juste pour permettre aux gens
chacun avec sa propre histoire de
trouver ses propres réponses vous et
d'en faire d'autres de courts métrages
ouais je vais me faire leur entrée dans
les comédies des gens
j'ai toujours été fascinée eric cantona
vous avez toujours été fascinée eric
cantona par rapport la frontière qui
entre la raison et la folie
je crois que ça remonte à l'époque où
vous accompagnez votre père qui
travaillait dans un hôpital
psychiatrique et vous avez été en
contact très très rapprochés et enfants
avec la avec la démence quoi c'est une
des éléments rassurants ça non ne
sachant pas ou qui sait où sont les
limites
une folie on sait pas donc on a tous
fascinés on est tous fascinés a
maintenant qu'on a peur de tout ça est
ce que vous pensez que c'est la cause
devaux pétage de plomb pendant votre
carrière sur les stades
non c'est la folie c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus inquiétant que ce à quoi
que c'est simple c'est un peu pétage de
plombs quoi c'est des interrogations
quotidiennes sur finalement des
finalement des questions on se pose on
se pose des questions tout le monde se
pose les mêmes questions
on trouve pas vraiment de réponse c'est
être et se regarder à travers un moment
donné ouais il ya des gens qui ne
supportent pas de pas trouvé de réponse
on est sur un fil comme ça voilà donc
c'est normal ils se pensent que la folie
c'est la normalité a lu ça je bruit de
la la la
l'ailé sud et les surréalistes sont
finalement des hyper réaliste et tout ce
qu'on doit faire pour composer c'est ça
la vraie folie
vous avez fait de la psychanalyse oui et
alors ça nous a fait du bien non c'est
pas parce que j'en ai jamais fait
charlotte me disais tout à l'heure que
ça vous a fait du bien ça m'a sauvé 13e
vibrer un chat joue vraiment charlotte
ça va mieux et vous laurent je les fais
de la finance
givet mardi je devais piscine le mardi
oui mais j'ai décalé en tous les cas
eric cantona cette folie quant aux nian
vous a été utile pour votre nouveau film
qui s'appelle l'outremangeur c'est un
film de thierry binisti qui sort le 16
juillet avec rachida brakni
[Musique]
oui bonsoir ils disent avoir sur le
plateau alors vous détestez vous qu'on
vous ramène toujours qu'on vous cantonne
à l'actrice d'origine algérienne ça vous
énerve qu'on parle de vous comme d'une
je dis tout de suite ce qui vous énerve
c'est chacun son truc voilà vous avez
pas qu'on vous appelle beurette vous
détester ce mot vous dites oui je suis
nourrie de culture algérienne mais je
suis française complètement française et
vous êtes tellement française que vous
êtes à la comédie-française donc voilà
alors vous avez joué antigone face à
créon blond 1
ce qui prouve que donc là il n'y a pas
de pas d'histoire de bord est et surtout
une reine allemand de maria deneufbourg
dans ruy blas de victor hugo
donc voilà donc quasiment on vous choisi
pour faire un grain allemande vous dites
que là il ya plus de la plus de
différence ouais tout à fait puisque
sans fin c'est l'expérience m'a permis
de le vérifier c'est que je me suis
rendu compte que c'était le jeu des
médias et pas du tout du public alors
vous dites que théâtre on recherche la
fibre de l'actrice alors qu'au cinéma on
n'est plus dans dans le physique ce qui
fait que ça marche moins bien
effectivement pour vous pouvez pas jouer
de rennes allemande au cinéma quoi vous
jouez plutôt qu'à au cinéma de coline
serreau
mais je pense que c'est pas demain la
veille que j'aurai un film de cape et
d'épée
peut-être je sais pas mais ce sera plus
dur
oui en tous les cas pour chaos de coline
serreau xvi le césar du meilleur espoir
féminin en 2002
bravo
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors même si je sais vous avez vu
un molière aussi mais c'est une arme
partant d'une renault le mans
aujourd'hui rachida vous et l affiche de
l'outremangeur de thierry binisti avec
eric cantona donc caroline si lol
richard bohringer jocelyn quivrin qui
sort comme je les dis le 16 juillet
alors c'est d'après la bd de jacques
ferrandez et de tonino benacquista
c'est un peu la belle et la bête quoi
version moderne version moderne mais
c'est il ya les éléments de la belle et
la bête dans la belle ville s'appelle
elsa est soupçonné du meurtre de son
oncle et la bête c'est vous c'est le
commissaire selena qui en échange de son
silence parce que vous savez que qu'elle
a commis le crime
vous lui dites écoute d'accord je vais
le dire à personne mais tu viendras
dîner c'est extraordinaire cette
histoire tu viendras dîner tous les
soirs chez moi de 21h à 23h pendant un
an
manutan diverses danses connu
on a envie de manger parce qu'on a envie
de rien c'est comme ça pour leur santé
[Musique]
thématique jean minjoz sommes toujours
seule sa commissaire salut mi-temps la
chaude plus grands armateurs du port
c'est sa femme la plus jeune de sa nièce
nasa c'est elle qui trouvait le corps je
la connais c'est moi qu'elle a appelé je
connais connaît celui du talent chez moi
il était à 9h ou 10h et parce que vous
avez corps pendant la prison pour le
meurtre de votre oncle
[Musique]
très qu'est ce que vous voulez vous pas
de mal à ça je vais être direct avec
vous madame à fond est ce que votre mari
avait une maîtresse suis le seul à
savoir que vous avez tué dans la chambre
a besoin de moi moi aussi je peux je ne
vous demande juste de venir chaque soir
de nouvelles rondeurs posé aucune
question
la zone à jour pour jour vous serez
livrés
si j'allais raconter qu'on peut chanter
vous dissimuler des preuves ne ferait
pas même plus rien à perdre en moi
regarde moi je
[Musique]
voilà l'outremangeur de thierry binisti
avec rachida brakni et eric cantona qui
sont nos invités ce soir l'ours
extraordinaire vous peser dans le film
sans fin 158 kg 40 kg de prothèses
quatre heures de maquillage avec votre
coup là comme ça avec du latex
absolument extraordinaire c'était
épouvantable non mais oui là je fais 160
kg en baisse et un peu il ya un peu de
tout et beaucoup de beaucoup d'effets de
prothèses de tout le maquillage est bon
on parle beaucoup de se lever à 5 heures
chez sylla mais je trouve que si on
garde les yeux ouverts sur le monde quoi
ouais ça permet de relativiser j'ai dû
finalement ça nous permet de nous
exprimer
on est payé cher ouais je vois c'est il
y en a qui se lève à 5h pour l'âme
filles et les trucs les unes derrière
les autres comme charlotte à l'époque
oui parlons bien sûr le soir vous aviez
dîner des fois tous les deux
on n'avait pas envie de manger après il
paraît comme que la nourriture était
bonne ça s'entend à bouffer mais enfin
les vacances prises avec des énormes
cotisation et le choix 9h du matin non
pas que je crois qu'il serait du port
vous comprenez tout ce qui vous dit et
quand on na waie ces expressions comme
ça lui c'est vrai on va voir on va faire
un quant au quiz
bon alors rachida on va commencer par
quelque chose de simple à une phrase
vraiment très connus d'eric cantona
quand les mouettes suivent le chalutier
c'est qu'elles pensent qu'on va leur
jeter des sardines ça veut dire quoi
voir si vous comprenez bien de cantona
bas que quand on donne la becquée aux
gens ils suivent comme des moutons
c'est ça que tu les as je veux pas
l'expliquer c'est dans c'est une phrase
qui va sortir un jour après laffaire
crystal palace j'avais beaucoup de
journalistes
il fallait qu'ils disent quelque chose
il a dit ça et puis voilà c'est parti et
voilà et c'est resté mondialement
célèbre savait que maintenant c'est
gravé au fronton des écoles dans
beaucoup de pays d'humour qui cette
phrase une très très belle passe à
l'écran non mais ce qui est important
c'est au delà des murs et est ce que ça
représente dans un certain contexte les
mots c'est finalement pas que c'est très
secondaire alors on continue rachida
donc avec le quant au quiz
la vie est toujours trop cruel tout ce
que nous pouvons faire est de laisser le
soleil brille et ben par rapport à ce
qu'ils disent est tout à leur faut
relativiser quand on se lève à 5 heures
du matin pour avoir quatre heures de
maquillage et qui en a d'autres qui se
lève pour aller travailler à la chaîne
ça va ouais c'est ça la trouver le bon
boulot en temps tu dis des conneries tu
laisses les gens expliqué
alors le ballon est vivant il répond à
mes caresses comme une femme d'esprit
que je réponde à ça alors mes obsèques
au foot on appellera touché le ballon
avec les mains
et oui et alors mais on peut caresser la
une femme avec les pieds par exemple que
didier deschamps c'est le frère de
belles des champs non
non c'est à lui qu'il dise il inscrit un
bon but est un but important est beau
pour moi le but le plus beau but qui
puisse exister puisque c'est un sport
collectif c'est au-delà d'un retourné
acrobatique de 30 mètres c'est toute
l'équipe qui touche le ballon à une
touche de balle et un mec qui finalement
le dernier va pousser le ballon enfin ça
c'est la perfection parce que la
perfection c'est le jeu simple dans tout
dans tout ce qu'on peut aborder dans la
vie la véritable perfection si à la
perfection
d'ailleurs jamais un but comme ça c'est
la pelure simplicité l'avez vous savez
que c'est là qu'ils m'ont fait penser là
à votre oncle lui qu'était ermite dans
la montagne
vous devenez vous avez cette espèce de
singe est bon mais c'est vrai mais c'est
mon idole
peut-être vous irez finir comme ça dans
la montagne dans une croix comme ça en
mangeant des jeunes n'auraient plus
aucune désir sexuel je partirai vie une
alimentation apportera des pichets de
lait de chèvre
voilà on viendra te voir interdire le
tacle par-derrière serait une bonne
chose
le tac interdire le tacle par derrière
c'est parce que le pas vers le lac à
toutes les soirées tout à fait ce serait
une bonne chose mais beaucoup de joueurs
n'auraient plus qu'à faire leurs valises
qu'est ce que ça veut dire rachida
brakni il faut recommencer fond de la
mer
il faut faire un stage c'est vrai que si
on peut pas tacler par derrière il y en
a beaucoup qui est un
il y en a qui jouent pour construire et
créer puis en a que je pour détruire
bancaire à cette phrase la france une
notice dit dan il est peut-être fort
mais il perd tous ses cheveux ce conte
pourquoi vous avez précisé que c'est pas
du moins c'est pas déjà assez content
tout ce que j'ai dit ah ben là c'est
pire
m
alors rachida donc j'ai dit que vous
refusiez de jouer la beurette de service
mais je veux quand même souligner un
destin exceptionnel parce que c'est un
vrai exemple
votre père était routier votre mère
femme de ménage à la maison tout le
monde parlait arabe
vous avez vécu étant jeune l'humiliation
de vos parents face à l'administration
et faso aux flics certaines fois et ça
vous énerver beaucoup parce que vos
parents payer des impôts
et malgré tout ils n'étaient pas traités
comme il faut en fait c'est le problème
de la langue quoi ces barrières c'est le
seul moyen qu'on a pour c'est le seul
moyen qu'on a en tout cas de de
communiquer avec les autres mes parents
ne parlait pas un mot de français et moi
très jeunes forcément j'ai été
responsabilisés c'est moi qui m'occupais
de toutes les tâches administratives
donc je me suis retrouvé grande très
très jeune en fait voilà alors vous avez
grandi dans une cité vous avez jamais
traîner trop un an dans les rôles de
non-jeu chiites s'étaient pas votre truc
vous dit le cliché qu'est ce tu casses
les couilles c'est pas pour moi vous
avez dit non c'est pas mon truc j'aime
pas quand on compte quand on cantonne
les gens à à certains clichés parce que
je trouve que ça veut dire qu'on croit
pas en la nature humaine quand on veux
excuser un jeune con par exemple de
faire de faire certains mais fait sous
prétexte qu'il est qu'il est d'origine
arabe ou qu'il est noir
j'aime pas ça parce que pour moi c'est
du colonialisme encore plus perdus
racisme à l'envers
oui puis c'est du colonialisme dans le
sens où certes ils ont quitté les pays
mais il ya une mainmise encore là dessus
c'est un peu de la vie de malek boutih
finalement je l'aï entendu une ou deux
fois et je dois dire que ouais j'ai été
renoués assez séduite par ce qu'ils
disaient alors qui est extraordinaire
c'est quand vous étiez enfant votre père
que c'est pas lire le français vous
acheter des livres mais au pif il savait
pas ce qu'il achetait c'est génial je me
souviens d'une fois j'étais
et j'avais été j'étais à l'hôpital et
mon père m'avait amené un bouquin et il
y avait ma voisine de chambre
une vieille dame qui a voulu voir le
bouquin elle était assez assez choqué
tout ce que mon père machin
c'était quoi ah oui citer les mémoires
d'un d'un mec prostituées et qui
racontait toutes ces expériences
voilà alors vous êtes rachida l'exemple
d'une intégration assez réussi qu'est ce
que ça vous fait de voir cette montée du
communautarisme en ce moment en france
c'est vrai qu en tout cas moi dans mon
tour dans mon entourage je remarque
depuis voilà depuis depuis quelques
depuis quelques années il ya un retour
comme ça mais dans toutes les religions
que des fins ceci dit je trouve que le
christianisme s'est le mieux
affranchi de tout ça mais en tout cas
dans le judaïsme et dans l'islam il ya
des gens qui sont re découvre tout d'un
coup une passion pour pour la religion
et qui moi me 9
ouais gj du mal quoi alors ici a eu des
moments très difficiles à ce sujet là
sur ce plateau notamment un beaucoup de
débats et est un qui nous a donné un peu
d'espoir c'était un débat entre leïla
shahid et élit chaque la chaîne bonsoir
bonsoir
donc vous n'êtes pas en baisse à driss
de palestine en france mais déléguée
générale de palestine en france
vous représentez yasser arafat dans
notre pays
le pape palestine héros c'est elie
barnavi a dit ici sur ce plateau il ya
quelques semaines
israël a perdu la guerre des médias
parce que quand on voit la télévision un
enfant avec une tient à la main face à
un char de tsahal
évidemment on est pour l'enfant et
ajouté t-il ce qu'on sait pas c'est que
derrière l'enfant avec la pierre à la
main il ya des hommes des adultes armée
qui pousse l'enfant je crois que les
gens ont regardé ce que la télévision
montre ça veut dire de la réalité en
direct une occupation militaire
or israël occupe militairement la
palestine avec ses 7 populations civiles
depuis 35 ans israël est une puissance
occupante et ce n'est jamais ce n'est
jamais bon
aucun gouvernement pour le connaître en
israël comme ailleurs dans le monde ce
n'était pas non plus très bien pour les
irakiens d'occuper le koweït
c'est pas une question de deux
populations autour d'un fait de réalité
politique
c'est vrai quand même que les
palestiniens aujourd'hui de meilleures
images moi je me souviens il ya trente
ans c'était la prise d'otage jeux
olympiques de munich
les palestiniens avaient vraiment une
image de terroristes terrible alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'était une image
objective unique a eu lieu ce n'était
pas seulement une image c'est une
réalité mais c'est vrai qu'on a occulté
le fait que c'était aussi un peuple
maintenant on voit que c'est tout un
peuple qui résiste contre l'occupation
qui depuis depuis trop longtemps il y a
dans cette population les personnes
armées les personnes qui ne seront pas
remis mais il ya en face sûrement une
des armées les plus puissantes du monde
je vais juste vous demander si la
palestine avait la même armée la même
puissance est-ce qu'elle ferait pas la
même chose
ah non pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ferait la
même chose puisque elle ne cherche pas
occupés israël la palestine a été une
société arabe avec des chrétiens des
musulmans et des juifs y avait une
communauté juive
c'est devenu un état israël hier qui a
malheureusement pris toute la place de
la palestine et la palestine a disparu
aujourd'hui les palestiniens proposent à
leurs ennemis à leur boulot à la
puissance qu'ils occupent de partager ce
pays on ne réclamant que moins d'un
quart mais nous exigeons aussi d'avoir
le droit d'exister souverain est vrai
livre à l'époque où les palestiniens
était peut-être moins considéré par par
l'opinion publique occidentale
vous aviez coutume de dire vous et puis
d'autres palestiniens
ben finalement c'est normal vous sentez
coupable par rapport au peuple juif
parce que vous avez cette honte de la
shoah est bien ce qui s'est passé pour
mac ipad bas de quelque chose c'est bien
vous pouvez pas non plus complètement
les palestiniens vous désengager de la
shoah parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on dit rarement m'enfin faut le dire
puisque c'est vrai c'est qu'en 1941
quand même le grand mufti de jérusalem
est allé voir hitler à berlin et qui
sont quand même prévu tous les deux
hitler lui a dit bon j'ai quelques
problèmes à régler mais après je vous
promets on va s'occuper des juifs qui
sont en palestine mélange complètement
et vous abstraire du prime de la shoah
non non mais là il n'y a jamais eu une
alliance politique entre les nazis
et palestiniens il y a eu comme dans
tout l'est toutes les alliances un
ennemi commun qui est à l'angleterre et
donc c'est pour ça que le moustique qui
luttent et vous l'avez dit contre la le
colonialisme britannique en palestine à
penser qu'ils peuvent faire alliance
avec les ennemis dont l'angleterre mais
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps et il
faut surtout pas mélanger l'histoire de
l'europe puisque le génocide a lieu en
europe et l'histoire du monde arabe
alors est-ce que vous pensez que in fine
et l'anti fada est une bonne chose pour
les palestiniens vous connaissez abou
mazen mais bien sûr a déclaré que la
deuxième intifada était une erreur qui a
engagé le peuple palestinien sur une
voie de destruction des acquis et que
finalement c'est un échec à long terme
moi je vous direz vous avez dit que ces
sociologues je pense que l'intifada net
une décision de personnes c'est un
mouvement social
c'est un mouvement de résistance civile
d'une population entière qui est saturé
d'humiliation de misère d'oppression et
surtout de de manque de liberté et que
ce n'est ni la décision de la sonara
fans et celle d'abou mazen les citoyens
lorsqu'ils résistent ils demandent la
permission de personnes ce que abou
mazen et c'est de dire c'est qu'il
fallait pas militarisée 7 cette révolte
cette résistance soulèvement il faut que
je vous dise que intafada en arabe ça
veut dire se relever ça veut dire lever
le menton reprendre confiance en soi
le plan de sa dignité ce n'est pas
contre quelqu'un mais c'est par rapport
à soi même
les lâchers de ce que vous avez déjà
rencontré ariel sharon non j'ai
rencontré monsieur bah là que j'ai
rencontré monsieur ps j'ai rencontré
monsieur rabin je n'ai pas rencontré
monsieur charbonneau
mais la chaise vide si vous étiez en
face d'ariel sharon
vous ne diriez quoi je lui dirai que si
vraiment c'est un patriote israélien
ils mènent sont pas pervers un suicide
parce que le choix militaire qu'il a
pris son refus de dialogue et de
négociation politique ne peut mener son
peuple qu'à un suicide que ce serait
tragique surtout s'il vaut que
l'histoire se rappelle de lui comme
l'homme qui a donné à israël une vie à
l'avenir et maintenant j'accueille elie
chouraqui
là
une joie qui vont soir soir aujourd'hui
je n'en peux plus
on n'en pouvons plus le monde n'en peut
plus à deux voix l'arc les enfants il ya
des gosses qui au lieu d'être avec leur
mère lancé des cailloux sur des tanks
qui a des idées mais non mais madame jeu
je veux lui dire qu'il ya des mères
juives qui pleurent leurs enfants comme
les maires palestiniens perdent peuples
ont les leurs moi je veux dire vous avez
l'oreille d'arafat évidemment vous êtes
sa représentante ici et il appartient de
vous parce que dans les dix dernières
années vous par les médias vous avez
fait un travail remarquable
vous avez été vraiment le prophète de la
palestine en france puisque vous avez
vous avez réussi à retourner totalement
l'opinion française et je vous tire mon
chapeau
donc si vous voulez c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dit arafat qu'il met
toute son énergie même avec son
téléphone portable uniquement pour
essayer de calmer le hamas et que
peut-être ce moment-là sharon calmera
les colons éclats et que et qu'à ce
moment là madame qu'il a et lui pour une
fois pour une fois qu'ils sortent en
disant voilà c'est moi aujourd'hui c'est
pas les israéliens qui dit fois sont
venus vers moi mais c'est moi
aujourd'hui qui va les israéliens et qui
leur dit je veux la paix ici et
maintenant comme il est dit dans dans
nos livres commun ici et maintenant je
vous promets que je le dirai au
président
et ils sont inquiets vous reprenez vos
lentilles à votre pompe cette phrase
d'andré chouraqui qui dieu c'est à
étudier tous les livres si les hommes
suivent et les dix commandements il
vivra en paix absolument vous savez je
me suis amusé à quelque chose avec andré
justement j'ai dit andré essayons
d'ajouter un commandement otan retranché
et on se rend compte c'est impossible
il y en a cinq qui concerne le dieu 5
qui concerne que ça notre vie
quotidienne oui tu ne trompera pas et
puis les autres c'est tu respectes unis
n'aura qu'un dieu etc
mais c'est vrai qui résume notre
existence sociale et religieuse au
quotidien et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
revient à notre notre discussion si les
palestiniens israéliens et les peuples
arabes l'an général et les peuples de la
bible du coran et du nouveau testament
respecter ses commandements là on
vivrait en se demandant à quelle heure
on déjeune ensemble alors vous dites
vous je suis un fan de moïse
c'est le seul homme à avoir dialogué
avec dieu est-ce que la morandais est ce
que pour les chrétiens pour les
catholiques
est-ce que moïse a la même importance
que pour les juifs non bien sûr puisque
l'importance principal et l'a nommé j'en
étais heureuse c'est jésus ainsi aïssa a
dit ray
les musulmans mais dont de ce côté là on
reconnaît que vous êtes nos enceintes
vous êtes nos aïeux nous dépendons de
vous c'est donc un véritable noeud pap a
dit les juifs sont les frères aînés de
l'église
oui mais pire pillon gênants comme la
prophète bien je suis allé chercher ça
moussa dans le pays présidera au
jugement dernier
j'ai rencontré une femme à new york je
suis très américaine en ce moment qui
m'a dit c'était une femme d'un banquier
lé libanaise d'obédience musulmane et
elle m'a dit j'étais très inquiète parce
que ils ont mis mon mari à la tête d'une
banque à new york et les principaux
clients d'une banque à new york c'est
les juifs
elle m'a dit on va se faire la malle est
arrivé à nuire aux et on va se faire
vraiment la mini et elle m'a dit mais ce
sont mes soeurs on a la même approche de
la famille on a la même approche
oui pour les enfants elle m'a dit mais
on aimait qu'on est comme ça ce sont mes
meilleurs amis j'ai découvert ça à new
york
agilité la palestine ce qu'on aime
beaucoup plus proche qui est un peu la
sienne suédois après que la future
un bon moment antonella chahid et vichot
à qui vous est dû regarder ça avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et déjà au moment où
cet entretien a eu lieu
le problème s'était déjà d'un côté les
colons israéliens qui sont implantées en
cisjordanie et de l'autre côté le
ramasse on voit que malgré la feuille de
route et malgré tout ce qui a été fait
ces dernières semaines pour rétablir la
paix au moyen-orient
les extrémistes n'ont pas rendu les
armes qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
dise ça qu'elle est ma légitimité moi je
suis qui mois pour donner mon avis là
dessus je crois pas avoir un avis plus
intéressant que que tous ceux qui sont
présents ici
après moi par rapport à ma sensibilité
ce que ce que je peux ressentir par
rapport à ce qui a été dit c'est j'ai
l'impression d'entendre des minots quoi
dit quoi toi le premier mois ça veut
dire quoi enfin en tout cas moi je
remarque mais au delà du problème
israélo-palestinien dans tous les
conflits qui peut y avoir à travers le
monde sait qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'humanistes il y en a plus et comme des
philosophes y en a il n'a plus des gens
qui qui au delà de leur appartenance
raciale culturelles religieuses ont une
vraie pensée sur sur l'avenir je vois
que des gens qui ne sont attirés que par
le pouvoir l'argent
non parce que les premiers qui en
souffrent c'est ce qui sait ce que c'est
ce qu'ils disaient tous les deux c'est
c'est les gosses c'est très facile de
monter le bourrichon aux gens parce
qu'ils ont pas ils ont pas les éléments
enfin ils ont ils ont pas eu la culture
ils ont pas eu l éducation ils ont pas l
ouverture quand on prend de part et
d'autre des gosses dès le plus jeune âge
en leur disant c'est lui ton ennemi
c'est un [ __ ] aussi tu es comme ça
c'est à cause de lui et vice versa dans
les deux sens c'est vrai que ce sera le
cas au total
mais la faisait pas eu le sentiment en
écoutant et les choix qui l ai la chance
d'avoir un peu plus d'humanisme que
d'habitude moi je ne me reconnais pas je
me reconnais pas là-dedans puisqu'un
qu'on est un con je je m'en fous de son
appartenance j'en ai vraiment mais rien
à [ __ ] mais après au delà de ça c'est
vrai que
c'est vrai que j'entends page entend pas
beaucoup en tout cas en france ces
discours là moi je sais par exemple sur
internet j'aime bien aller regarder lire
le journal haaretz il ya un journal où
il ya vraiment des articles de très très
beaux articles la gauche et le rennais
ne n'arrive pas souvent on n'arrive pas
souvent en france en europe en général
mais bon c'est eric que dirait votre
votre oncle ermite en voyant ça moi ce
que je veux dire longtemps que je me
suis rendu à l'évidence que c'est le
pouvoir et l'argent qui dirigent le
monde et que tous ces discours sont des
discours d'utopistes et que
malheureusement les gens qui veulent la
paix sont des gens qui se font crever et
que ça sera toujours comme ça et qu'ils
en connaissent pas avoir alors on
profite de la foi des gens on les
manipule les enfants comme de la pâte à
modeler on a fait ce qu'on en veut au
nom du pouvoir
on se sert de la religion pour diriger
le monde tout simplement
il faut pas rêver on restera
malheureusement là dessus avec
[Musique]
maintenant
voici robert smith des cure
[Musique]
bonsoir
robert smith des brochures nous sommes
très heureux de vous avoir sur ce
plateau robert smith une énorme star
alors pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent
pas il n'y a qu'une solution
diddy
[Musique]
ça
m
je
là
[Musique]
mais ceux-là
tha
[Musique]
m
es tu
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
oui
ma
[Musique]
et toutes tailles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'était la musique story berthier
ces neuf ans
alors incident à vous tous c'est tout
votre jeu mais cela qui vient de défiler
en quelques en quelques morceaux mais
j'étais fan j'avais j'avais un poster
dans ma chambre au grand export de mon
père le jeune succès n de banshee
c'était un sélecteur coiffé comme ça
qu'il voulait trouver
qu'est ce que ça fait robert d'entendre
toute son oeuvre comme ça des filets en
quelques minutes
ça décoiffe
alors 2002 à berlin vous avez joué
l'intégralité de trois de vos albums sur
scène et ce concert plus des bonus dont
une interview de vous de 30 minutes
sortant double dvd
[Musique]
tour 2 dvd magnéto ch
oui
tu mets
[Musique]
vous
pour le double dvd est en vente alain
robert smith vous avez 44 ans vous êtes
né en 1959 à blackpool au bord de la mer
dans le nord ouest de l'angleterre
et vous avez des souvenirs comme ça
parce que votre votre père filmer tout
en super 8 et vous regardez des films on
vous voit courir sur la plage avec des
ânes à l'arrière-plan
vous allez voir une faute est bien
informé j'ai des souvenirs du coup du
sable de caen était très petit de
l'odeur des anneaux c'est vrai c'était
l'un des aspects de la plage à blackpool
fric et encore des ânes qui court sous
la plage de da cruz peau vous vous
souvenez quand vous des terriers les
vers de terre pour les faire manger à
votre soeur bain et je m'en souviens
c'est tout à fait mais elles avaient
toujours tendance à me donner le vomi de
ces animaux à manger à moi alors 13 ans
vous avez votre première guitare et puis
ensuite vous montez vos premiers groupes
fait beaucoup à l'époque de reprise de
jimmy hendrix avait alors 76 c'est
l'arrivée du punk des sex pistols
là vous montez votre groupe qui
s'appelle d'abord easy cours en 77 et un
jour vous réagissez à une annonce dans
le journal
une annonce d'un label qui s'appelle en
deçà
qui dit vous voulez vous devenir une
star et là évidemment vous enregistrer
une cassette dans la salle à manger de
vos parents et ça marche
nous avons fait effectivement quelques
démos on a proposé mais enfin la fin ils
se sont débarrassés nous parce qu'ils ne
l'aient pas notre musique m'offrait
pierre cannes ça il voulait que vous
fassiez que dès que des reprises en fait
il voulait pas vos chansons originales
et puis alors ça ça vraiment en frites
et quand vous êtes arrivé avec votre
single qui s'appelait killing en arabe
tuer un arabe alors évidemment ça fait
scandale dans la maison de disques est
en fait vous s'était inspiré par le
meurtre absurde
de l'étranger de meursault dans le
bouquin de camus mais c'est vrai qu'en
angleterre ce titre killing en arabe a
été récupéré par le national franz qui
est un petit peu en france le front
national une seule chose que je regrette
en toute ma vie c'est effectivement le
titre de cette chanson parce qu'à 17
temps il me semblait que tout le monde
s'intéresserait autant que moi albert
camus et où moscou prendrait le look est
existentiel de mains d'albert camus et
ce titre m'avait obsédé en tant que
coauteur mais évidemment on a toujours
on a pensé qu'il s'agissait disons dans
l'appel au meurtre hostilités notamment
lorsqu est sympa par contre c'est que au
cours des années j'ai pu faire connaître
l'existentialisme français à l'étranger
bien sûr vous avez fait beaucoup pour
pour kamerhe effectivement alors malgré
tout vous vous devenez rapidement culte
et autour de vous on assiste à
l'émergence de ce qu'on a appelé le look
gothique avec beaucoup de pulsions
suicidaires des pulsions homicide ni
liste deux choses du côté un peu
ténébreux que je pouvais présenter
explique le groupe qui faisait un peu
les marioles ça a commencé comment votre
coiffure tous les dix ans je coûte
toujours à sous et je recommence à zéro
et pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
maquiller aussi raison que les acteurs
et les actrices présentes me permet de
me présenter sous un jour plus
flamboyant privé de mon maquillage je me
sens un peu plus réservés vous avez un
côté un peu lisse taylor poche tron est
quand même
[Musique]
ça
juste parce qu'à chaque fois quelque
chose tout le monde rigole et je suis
pas toujours sûr de confondre la blague
vous avez pris beaucoup de drogue un
robert ici non pas ici vous dites j'ai
eu peur à force de me griller les
neurones et de plus reconnaître personne
waouh t'es troisième chose que j'ai pu
reconnaître comme un jeu des situations
de danger
par exemple j'ai pu voir que je risquais
de me griller les neurones ou maj de
cette présence d'esprit mais vous même
nature ne ne permet pas de formuler une
opinion sur mes propres expériences
directement star est un exemple pour des
millions de jeunes est ce que vous
pourriez dire à la télé que la drogue
c'est pas bien disons que on ne comprend
pas toujours ce que c'est la drogue
je ne dirais pas que toutes les drogues
sont mauvaises l'histoire nous a montré
qu' il ya des civilisations qui ont
utilisé des drogues différentes
différentes fins et si elles sont
utilisées de manière positive ça peut
être une bonne chose mais la culture
occidentale à diaboliser la drogue à
telle enseigne que maintenant là on en a
fait quelque chose de complètement
tanner médias bon le tabac par exemple
ça c'est une mauvaise trop de robert
smith et on peut dire que vous en tous
les cas pour vous débarrasser de la
drogue la religion n'a été d'aucun
d'aucun secours
parce que vous aviez un frère aîné qui
était hippie qui étaient revenus d'asie
écrit et qui passait son temps à mettre
de l'encens la cuisine de vos parents et
c'est vrai que ça faisait tellement
d'histoires que la religion ne vous a
pas semblé une une vraie solution à ma
famille était catholique et ça c'est une
bonne recette pour se transformer en
meubles jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
alors vous dites je connais peu de gens
que la religion est rendu meilleur ou
plus heureux c'est grave quand même ça
désinvolte par rapport à ça mais la
notion de choix c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours un
riquet personnellement je n'ai aucune
foi en quoi que ce soit sauf ce que
j'arrive à voir de mes yeux est touchée
de mes doigts mais je sais qu
effectivement il ya des gens qui ont une
fois absolument incroyable et je les
envie j'aimerais bien voir ça cette fois
mais au fond je me dis est ce que il ne
faut pas que de se bercer d'illusions
vous êtes comme ça chez d'avant j'ai en
partie d'accord avec ce qu'il dit la
fois pour moi il doit être personnel
intime mais elle doit pas être dévoilés
d'une mare puis il ya des psys aussi en
qui on peut en qui on peut mettre un peu
tous et tous ses espoirs la religion
souvent pour moi c'est celle et
désespéré qui ont besoin ça peut être
noble celle ci on pensait pas que ces
désespérés non si haut si elle se situe
le way
parce que vous vous êtes allé voir un
psy si vous aviez eu la foi vous seriez
allé voir un curé non répond voilà je
suis athée et si on veut régler le
problème
faisons en sorte que plus personne ne
croit en rien si ce n'est à lui même et
à l'être humain voilà et tout ce qui
au-delà spirituel machin ça c'est fait
pour manipuler le peuple pour manipuler
les gens en faire ce que l'on veut et
faire marcher le pouvoir et au nom de
quoi de la religion c'est la religion
qui détruit tout qui détruisent l'être
humain la religion ne détruis l'être
humain à mon avis et vous pensez pas
les ombres les psychanalystes exactement
pareil qui se raccroche aux
psychanalystes comme avant se raccrocher
aux curés séparation un petit monsieur
l'addition rires un psychanalyste c'est
julie rentrée d'amendements d'intérieur
dans toute mon histoire dans mon
inconscient et à travers ça c'est ma
propre histoire et à travers ça j'essaie
d'en sortir quelque chose
la religion ne sais quoi c'est une
croyance une croyance et quoi s'étonner
je crois plus à rien c'est aujourd'hui
je crois que quelque chose si je me
raccroche à quelque chose mais rien de
concret alors vous avez déclaré à
l'audience me je suis blasé aujourd'hui
je suis devenu blasé et je me suis fait
c'est terrible cette phrase je me suis
fait à l'idée que la vie n'avait pas à
être extraordinaire on voit le monde en
soit potentiellement est un nombre
absolument fabuleux rien qu'à regarder
nature c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
la notion même d'existence est
extraordinaire et je ne vois pas
pourquoi il faut quelque chose de plus
que cela il suffit de regarder les
étoiles et vous avez des l'a déjà toute
la merveille du monde
c'est vrai que le monde peut paraître
horrible mais il faut quand même se dire
que dans la plupart des cas la religion
c'est ça qui rend le monde horrible
je remercie le curé cantona
deviendraient des meilleurs amis du
monde
alors aujourd'hui robert vous croyez
plus en rien ne vous avez quand même un
sens moral vous pourriez pas faire comme
morceau justement on en revient à
l'étranger de camus pour il pas faire
comme meursault allez tu as là justement
que quand même l'absence de dieu ne
signifie pas qu'il faut pas avoir de
moralité virton la notion de moralité
pourquoi faut-il que la morale viennent
de dossiers d'un dieu un être humain
peut savoir ce qui est bon et ce qui
n'est pas bon ma philosophie à moi et
avec d'accord avec ça je suis d'accord
c'est prévu surtout magnifique sur agout
les gens étaient comme ça à penser comme
ça je suis allé
alors je vais mieux
ggd
j'accueille m'attend consoli vielles
giesbert et avant
[Musique]
bonsoir voir alors vous êtes né le 18
janvier 49 êtes capricorne
ouais comme moi je suis né le 6 janvier
quarante vernet vraiment un
voilà à wilmington vous dans 2 2 la
warner fait aux usa votre père était
américain artiste-peintre il a fait le
débarquement en normandie le 6 juin 44
il a rencontré votre mère une demande
comment la chanson voilà made in
normandie
mais dean en tant qu'aliment et vous
avez vécu jusqu'à l'âge de 3 ans vos
premières années en amérique aux états
unis alors là c'est incroyable à 18 ans
vous écrivez votre premier article dans
la liberté dimanche au sujet des
élections présidentielles américaines
qui avaient lu un an plus tard ensuite
vous rentrez aussi et angie le centre de
formation des journalistes fait la page
littéraire de paris-normandie ensuite en
fait une carrière très très rapide
71 vous entrez au nouvel observateur 85
vous êtes directeur de la rédaction du
nouvel observateur a traîné en 98 de
fait la même chose au figaro et en l'an
vous devenez directeur du point voilà ça
va vous allez voir calmels a donc avoué
oublier que j'ai quand même commencé à
écrire des bouquins vert
dix ans bref trop a fait un bébé a bien
entendu il était quand même bouquin
c'est beaucoup au jeu si je pense que
j'ai dû écrire un roman par an entre
l'âge de
dix et vingt ans mais heureusement
qu'ils n'ont pas été publiées je vois
mon frère les abonnés du mrc esclaves ya
plein de bouquins de vous qui ont été
publiés et des romans récemment je me
souviens de la souille pour lequel vous
avez reçu ici qui est un roman très
intéressant alors parallèlement au fait
de la télévision en culture et
dépendances donc sur france 3 alors page
116 du livre que vous publiez vous fait
le portrait d'un animateur d'émissions
culturelles à la télévision je gagne le
lire parce que je parlais pas de moi
donc je peux le lire volontiers parlé de
vous chaussant pour êtes vous non je me
dit un personnage en chemise bleue passe
trôner au milieu de ses invités moi j'ai
pas de chemise bleue l'air ahuri des
insomniaques
excusez moi c'est plutôt vous un oeil
plus petit que l'autre et qui dit lui
dis merde c'est encore vous ça donnait
un peu tordu les cheveux trop longs pour
son âge avancé c'est bien mais qui parle
de lui qui trahissez la neige sur la
tête voilà un soupçon de couperose son
chien il parlait des nouvelles tendances
de l'amour avec une psychanalyste une
prostituée un romancier algérien un mec
et démission à son retour est un jeune
homme blême à la mode qui semblait l'eau
dans la vanne ou isme là on dirait une
émission d'ardisson ouais ouais le
plateau c'est ce que vous avez là ce
soir
voilà non mais je n'ai pas de main morte
avec vous même je trouve c'est bien
comme ça on va pas trop vous critiquez
puisque moi évidemment on ne souriez pas
écrit ça je vous aurais crise il faut
pas se prendre au sérieux et a aidé moi
j'écris pour m'amuser
il ya un personnage qui est dit dans le
bouquin si lui il incarne la culture à
la télévision il ne nous reste plus qu'à
tirer la chasse d'eau
ouais ouais en parlant de vous bah oui
c'est un personnage qui le dit hein
c'est pas moi c'est les romands ils sont
écrits par d'autres je ne sais même pas
requis d'ailleurs mais ça avance et
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même un truc
que vous puissiez donner une petite
fessée comme son récent est assez dur
avec vous même il ya un truc que vous
dites pas franz olivier giesbert c'est
que je vous ai vu certains soirs plus
tôt dans le gai savoir mais même dans
culture et dépendances recevoir un un
écrivain à dire bonsoir alors votre
bouquin et à ce moment là vous lisiez la
quatrième de couverture vrai ou pas oui
mais là c'est vrai c'est vrai mais je ne
découvre pas le livre
c'est à dire que moi j'ai pas vraiment
de fiches comme vous je veux m vous
savez très bien c'est que quand on la
personne arrive on a tellement de choses
dans la tête que rien n'est pire que des
cours chez le non aux caravanes de temps
en temps assez pour ça ben oui vous avez
raison de le souligner non vraiment on
voit qu'il serait laborieux je pensais
que vous découvrirez en tout cas comme
un couperet sur les bateaux quand vous
faites de la télévision et c'est pour ça
que vu mon grand tu as je pourrais pas
continuer à en faire tu as longtemps
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'activités par
ailleurs mais c'est que c'est un tel
travail de lire tout ça de en général
d'ailleurs vous avez passé presque la
nuit blanche la veille de
l'enregistrement
mais c'est vrai que les zones en tête
des sélections à se mélanger et
brusquement bas vous trompez d'après
deux prénoms des choses qui arrivent de
temps en temps alors dans ce livre vous
en prenez évidemment à vous en tant qu
animateur de télévision mais aussi aux
journalistes page 54
or là c'est terrible je conseille
lecture de ça ils se croient enchères et
des gazages et continuent leurs sermons
gnangnan ça arrive non c'est fou quand
il comme vous qui allez diriger plein de
journaux nouvel obs le figaro le point
vous soyez aussi du site sur les
journalistes
je crois qu on vit dans un monde où sont
les journalistes qui donne des leçons
mais
les hommes politiques ou les autres ou
les personnalités du showbiz auront
toujours un peu de mal à donner des
leçons au journalisme moi je mise en jeu
je leur prête ma plume
le procédé très habile en fait parce que
vous commencez par taper sur vous en
tant qu animateur de télévision les
journalistes en tant que patrons de
presse les critiques donc voila c'était
assez mal d'ailleurs vous commencez par
vous couvrir de sambre je suis
traitements couverts de sang donc je
peux tout me permettre à ce que j'ai
écrit sur moi est proprement dégueulasse
c'est vrai c'est vrai alors à passer
justement au livre s'appelle l'abatteur
franz-olivier giesbert et c'est publié
chez gallimard dans la collection noire
[Musique]
alors là batteur c'est celui qui abat la
bête et c'est vrai que c'est un polar ça
vous intéressez robert smith
c'est un polar avec du sang partout il
est question sans arrêt dégorgement de
chirurgie on boit du sang soo vendant du
son dans les polars ouais non mais là
quand même à la la c'est quand même
gorin il ya des égorgements ya l'amour
de la poésie fait cuire du sandre non
mais c'est très sérieux maintenant vous
savez bien dire
il n'y a pas que ça c'est à dire que au
milieu de cet univers complètement
cannibale maryse sastre la fliquer
kiffel enquête puisque c'est un polar
elle est végétarienne alors évidemment
il ya un contraste absolu comme vous
justement alors vous vous êtes
végétarien mais d'une drôle de façon
sûre que vous mangez les bêtes à plumes
mais pas les bêtes à poils je suis
végétarien depuis longtemps par
sensiblerie ouais ça commençait à la
campagne parce que le cri du cochon
avait quelque chose de trop humain quand
on égorgeait dans la maison dans la
ferme d'à côté donc j'ai très vite
éliminé de cochon les chèvres parce que
c'est celle d'une échéance aussi
intelligente que les chiens sont des
petits animaux merveilleux dont j
arrivais pas je pouvais pas manger de la
chair c'est un coverage sur la vache la
vache lavage est tellement intelligente
est tellement douce et wall e vo le vous
c'est pas possible
et finalement rayé de fil en aiguille ce
qu'on me permettre cette meilleure
expression
j'ai pratiquement éliminer toutes les
bêtes à poils alors tous à cette idée de
respecter tout ce qui existe dans la
nature ça nous amène à pythagore parce
que votre bouquin en dehors d'être en
pôle art c'est aussi un livre
pythagoriciens cette idée que l'âme
comme ça air à travers les siècles et
les chairs et que finalement une espèce
de deux chaînes de réincarnation c'est
quand on a été élevé à la campagne il
reste toujours quelque chose ou à la
campagne
le fermier le paysan il parle aux bêtes
tout le monde parle bête et moi quand
j'étais petit quand j'étais enfant je
parlais aux bêtes bah ouais on est tous
fait de la même façon c'est-à-dire m'a
trouvé une âme dans les dents les
animaux alors dire
à partir de là je suis pythagoriciens
non mais c'est vrai que je trouve ça
intéressant vous êtes intéressé par ce
taux d'intérêt alors votre monde quand
même c'est un monde sans dieu alors les
une grande conversation tout à l'heure
ici vous ne croyez pas du tout vous je
conduis enfin je sais pas si c'est
l'amour autre chose et pas comment enfin
je crois que je crois quelque chose qui
nous dépasse
ouais ouais oui il ya encore 1 à
convaincre et à cheminer avec ça moi je
veux convaincre personne
vous me demandez mon avis je vous dis ce
que je pense chacun lui son truc pour ça
des discours du de mâcher chacun de
montrer l'exemple dans son petit monde
quand je dis on n'est rien quand on est
une goutte d'eau dans l'océan rentrer
dans des discours de machines ciel moi
je vous dis nous dit ce que j'en pense
mais je vais lui en situation de chacun
d'entre eux je pense aussi qu'on est une
goutte dans l'océan genre n'y avait rien
à vanity des vanités enfin tout est dans
l'ecclésiaste
oui oui en fait je sais pas c'est quoi
c'est un joueur
nous aimons c'est très bien c'est très
bien il faut le relever à part ça il ya
une vraie intrigue avec de vrais
personnages beaucoup de suspense alors
ya un personnage principal qui s'appelle
marie alors c'est terrible parce qu'elle
atteintes d'eczéma
alors c'est toujours bien vous dites
quand le héros se débat dans les
difficultés de la vie courante
vous dites c'est une démangeaison
vivante cette gonzesse se grattent sans
arrêt elle se gratter même puisqu'elle x
y
c'est cher jusqu'au sans quoi ces
cétacés particulier parce qu'on voit
bien qu'elle joue un petit peu en se
grattant ce qui arrive à tout le monde
vous avez un bouton ça vous arrive à
mêler les sang et or la tendance est
inverse certain plaisir
elle attendait devant noir pour se
gratter quand il ya un plaisir à se
gratter
c'est une expérience personnelle vous
gratter beaucoup non ça m'arrive de voir
sao tomé - ouais d'accord alors c'est à
elle donc amaril sastre 7 fliquette
qu'on confie la sphère de la tête coupée
et puis là il ya un truc génial
au début à la fin de votre bouquin c'est
que le narrateur en fait est un des
personnages ça j'avais jamais vu ça
c'est pas de ma faute ça c'est que en
fait j'ai apporté ce livre aux éditions
gallimard est un jeune éditeur aurélien
masson qui s'occupe de la collection
noire a dit m coco ça va pas du tout
parce qu'il ya un narrateur comme ça qui
fait les digressions qui tu t'en donne
son point de vue
alors ça peut aller dans un roman normal
ce que j'avais toujours écrit jusqu'à
fin mai dans un roman policier c'est
impossible parce que c'est vrai que dans
le roman policier à telle point doit
être vrai et c'est vrai il m'a dit mais
là ça va pas se dire acteur il faut que
ce soit quelqu'un est donc à cause d'un
maçon effectivement le narrateur ce
n'est plus moi c'est quelqu'un d'autre
c'est génial et j'aurais profité d'un
pur ajoute ont rajouté un peu sur mon
portrait ouais mais il y en avait déjà
pas mal ramé c'est extraordinaire parce
que donc au début
quelqu'un qui vous dit voilà moi je suis
le narrateur je dirai pas qui je suis et
à la fin on découvre qui c'est moi je
vais quand même donné un indice
le narrateur à la même profession que
votre maman d'accord
alors la question franz-olivier giesbert
c'est toujours la même c'est à dire vous
faites le point vous faites france 3
plus beaucoup d'autres choses vous êtes
membre de tout un tas de deux clubs
abbassi exagéré match et quand même vous
allez bien dans ces réunions du siècle
par exemple vous y allez quand même
beaucoup
non mais je vais y aller d'ailleurs là
et je suis retournée parce que chercher
du travail
quand on vous demande quand vous avez le
temps d'écrire tout ça vous dit bah oui
j'écris tout le temps des fois je suis
un taxi comme ça je sors à bout de
papier j'écris moi j'ai lu votre bouquin
c'est pas de genre de bouquin qu'on
écrit dans les taxis quand même hein
alors c'est vrai j'ai pas le temps je
n'ai absolument pas le temps réel et
comment vous fait quand il ya du désir
dans la ville
ah bon on le voit quand il ya du désir
c'est à dire un type par exemple qu'il
ya deux trois femmes ça arrive il a
tombé amoureux d'une quatrième il va
trouver le moyen de l'avoir et tout en
maintenant son travail parce qu'elle est
j'aimerais un bon désir
mon désir la nuit c'est peut-être pour
ça d'ailleurs je pas d'autre chose que
l'on désire la nuit c'est d'écrire est
donc mal c'est une chance c'est une
chance aussi à malheur parce que temps
en temps vous savez le problème de
l'insomniaque on a tendance à voir des
complots partout et c est donc à ce
moment là il faut dormir un petit peu se
calmer et ça va très vite c'est à dire
on n'est jamais fatigué et c'est vrai
que moi j'ai la chance de me réveiller à
80000 matin avec voilà je mets tout à
fait l'ambiance et la chaleur je me
couche tôt - ouais ouais j'aime beaucoup
ce genre minuit bah vous dormez le cadre
à parme et à la 84ème c'est ça les
regarde et vous faites le compte
ça fait 3 heures de travail en plus je
pourrais faire ça qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire ça ici vous pourriez faire ça vous
dormir quatre à part mais moi je dors au
moins huit heures au moins huit heures
oui et encore c'est un minimum
au moins huit heures
chez gallimard la noire
franz olivier giesbert cet hiver j'ai
piqué une idée c'est à dire que quand le
livre d'alain minc est sorti vous aviez
recueilli des interviews de tous les
gens de tous les groupes de toutes les
communautés qui était mise en cause dans
le livre d'anna mac et je vous ai piqué
l'idée vous l'avez fait dans le point
voilà ce que ça a donné vous allez me
dire si c'est si c'est bien fait
j'espère magnéto serge alors le pitch du
livre est très simple un à la menthe dit
le conformisme a changé de camp ce n'est
plus le vieux conformisme bourgeois qui
règne mais un nouveau conformisme
politiquement correct qui est imposée
dit-il par nos nouveaux maîtres
alors le nouveau maître son os auraient
selon quand on adhère ou non à la thèse
d'alain minc
les féministes les gays les
communautaristes les ong les anti
américain les anti mondialisation
vous dites qu aujourd'hui l'idéologie
dominante c'est celle de ceux qui ont
l'intelligence de se présenter comme des
dominés et c'est pas si l'on était oui
qu'ils ont été filmées qui aujourd'hui
ont l'intelligence de se présenter
encore comme les dominer quand vous
dites qu aujourd'hui on vit sous la
dictature d'un certain nombre de
minorités finalement oui sous une
pression très forte de ses minorités qui
fait qu'il ya des choses qu'on n'ose pas
dire bon le concept en sac le
conformisme me semble-t-il a changé de
sens où deux camps alors on va prendre
ses nouveaux maîtres
un parent alors on va commencer avec les
féministes pour vous dites vous la la
lutte pour l'égalité s'est mué en un
combat pour la différence homme femme et
ça c'est la porte ouverte évidemment au
communautarisme ne me répondait pas
elle est âgée
précise isabelle alonso
[Musique]
alors ils avaient d'alençon bonsoir vous
êtes président donc des chiennes de
garde
finalement vous vous réagissez assez
assez violemment aux bouquins d'alain
minc et aux propos qui qu'il tient sur
les féministes quand il dit le féminisme
est la matrice involontaire du
communautarisme déjà vous involontaire
se dire que les femmes font des choses
sans le faire exprès ce qui est pas très
sympa et un peu con way donc vous dites
les femmes composent la moitié de toutes
les communautés et que finalement
accuser les féministes de la matrice de
communautarisme c'est quelque chose
d'inepte pour vous oui je trouve que
c'est c'est pas très bien analysé enfin
j'étais j'ai été assez surprise en fait
de voir depuis tra lors vous avez dit
que c'était pas des épîtres mais j'étais
un pitre non j'ai dit dans l'épître ya
pitre
c'était dur est fait avec plus de
raffinement et c'est ce que j'ai trouvé
effectivement que c'était c'est que
quand j'ai vu que vous vous intéressiez
au féminisme sur le moment j'étais
contente parce que je me disais c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose auquel les
les élites qui nous gouvernent et qui
nous contrôle ne ne pense pas très
souvent
donc j'étais plutôt content tu es et
puis quand j'ai lu votre votre texte qui
fait qu'ils aient pas très longs en même
temps donc il assez vite lui eh ben je
m'aperçois que je suis maintenant moi
une maître à penser maîtresse à penser
que je suis devenu de dominer je suis
devenue dominante mais pensez si je suis
ravi parce que si moi je suis dominante
est que monsieur minc est dominée
monsieur minc
vous êtes un homme blanc quinquagénaire
français
énarque et je ne crois pas m'avancer en
disant que vous êtes hétérosexuels donc
toutes ces caractéristiques font de vous
exactement
une partie du noyau qui tient absolument
toutes les manettes du pouvoir dans ce
pays et d'ailleurs dans la planète nous
faisait la seule chose c'est que vous
allez donc aux rentes et maintenant
dominé et moi dominante mais je vous dis
on échange tout de suite votre position
contre la mienne je prends votre
fauteuil au monde et vous allez
retrouver les délices long
pari tenu pari tenu le monde contre
ruquier vous aviez totalement raison
quand éclate le coup de tonnerre du
deuxième sexe en effet la condition
féminine est une condition aliénés et il
ya une femme qui sonne pour la première
fois la révolte en 40 ans vous avez
gagné ce combat
mais tant mieux il fallait que vous le
gagner mais ne pensez pas que vous êtes
encore dans la position le prix
maintenant on se connaît tous milieu du
gué sur la tête c'est nous qui l'avons
le pied sur la tête thierry non mais
c'est vrai faudrait déjà avoir un débat
un peu sérieux rien sur ce sujet lorsque
je sens que déjà on va passer à autre
chose
c'est autre chose
alors invaincu dans votre livre vous
parlez des quais alors ce qui vous
énerve c'est que cette communauté la
communauté gay revendique à la fois le
droit à l'indifférence et le droit à la
différence alors effectivement ils ont
maintenant dites vous tous les droits
plus celui de se constituer en lobby une
espèce de maçonnerie très puissantes
comme les autres voilà un ni plus ni
moins comme l'est les propres caste
auquel j'appartiens je fais la
comparaison
ça évitera l'argument tout à l'heure
voici jean luc romero
[Musique]
alors jean luc romero bonsoir vous êtes
le premier membre du rpr à s'afficher
ouvertement homosexuel tu devais repères
wii aura de l'ump est le premier élu
français à avoir fait publiquement état
de votre séropositivité aujourd'hui vous
êtes conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
est alors donc d'après alain minc
vous voulez tout c'est à dire le mariage
entre un homme bon le fax disant
l'adoption des enfants et que j'étais
pour le mariage l'adoption et la
procréation médicale assistée enfin tout
comme les autres donc mais en gardant le
droit d'être différent et vous organisés
en un lobby surpuissant alors qu'on
veuille tout j'en suis pas tout à fait
persuadé parce que dans la communauté
gay je sais pas contrairement à ce que
vous pouvez dire monsieur minc ya pas
une unité dans la communauté on veut pas
tous la même chose en tout cas moi ce
que je constate aujourd'hui c'est que
les gays c'est pas des citoyens comme
les autres
contrairement à ce que vous dites c'est
quand même toujours des sous citoyens
parce que c'est vrai pour cette chantage
compassionnel non mais attendez en
revendique des drones on les a pas ses
droits
ce que j'aimerais entendre de la part
des deux ceux des gays qui s'expriment
le plus sur la place publique il y en a
quand même un certain nombre c'est de
dire le jour où nous aurons les mêmes
droits que chacun est bien on en viendra
à ce mot que pierre bergé utilisant
disant être homosexuel c'est comme être
gaucher et quand on joue une partie de
tennis et bien on la joue entre autres
wathier et est gaucher orillia vous le
savez très bien
une forme de renfermement quand même à
l'intérieur de la communauté gaie comme
aux états unis venir lire san francisco
se reproduit un peu à paris qui peut
faire craindre que même quand vous aurez
acquis les droits auquel vous aspirez
vous resterez enfermé sur vous même
est-ce que vous accepter l'idée de
penser que dans un grand magasin au
printemps vous ayez un département ou
alors les musulmans iront trouver
les vêtements qu'ils ont envie de voir
où les juifs iront chercher leur kippa
ou les gains iront à la section gay
friendly mais enfin c'est entrer dans un
univers fou et s'est pas excusé moi
accès en mai à temps vous avez l'air de
croire qu'aujourd'hui il est simple
d'être homosexuel lors peut-être dans le
marais ivème arrondissement il n'y a
aucun problème mais quand vous vivez au
fin fond de la corrèze à tulle je peux
vous assurer qu être homosexuel
aujourd'hui même si à paris on s'est
battu pour la main que dans votre livre
vous en prenez également aux petits
juges 2 synonyme de redresseur de ce
corps si les derniers instants et avide
de toujours plus de pureté à travers des
instructions mais si à grand spectacle
ne me répondez pas car voici
[Musique]
las il juge eric halphen
il les a tous
alors eric halphen bonsoir et agissant
en disponibilité et auteur d'un livre
intitulé ces temps de solitude
alors quand alain minc parle de
complexes médiatico judiciaire comme il
existe aux usa un complexe militaro
industriel
quand il dit que tous les petits juges
comme vous et petits jusqu'à 1 c'est un
compliment 1
voyez le lien a tellement vous êtes
avide de notoriété c'est vous fait quoi
je trouve que il a un peu tendance à ne
voir dans les juges que ceux dont on
parle
ouais il n'y a pas que les juges qui
s'occupe du pénal et aussi des justes
qui s'occupe du civ il ya un pas qui est
juge qui s'occupe des affaires
médiatiques aux financières ou politico
financières il ya des juges qui tous les
jours quotidiennement font leur travail
dans leur cabinet sans que personne ne
leur demande rien et quant au complexe
de la notoriété parce que j'avoue que
souvent c'est un peu c'est un peu des
phrases qu'on retrouve un peu partout à
savoir les juges en fait ils ne font des
perquisitions que comportera il ne
convoque les gens que pour les caméras
ils seront avides de voir leur nom dans
les journaux ou leur tête à la télé
d'abord moi je veux dire que
personnellement je ne me suis pas sentie
visée puisque j'ai toujours refusé
d'aller sur les plateaux de télé tant
que j'étais en fonction c'est vrai
première chose et deuxième chose être
juge c'est quand même le seul métier qu
on n'exerce pas pour avoir la notoriété
quand on est juge on s'attend uniquement
à chercher la vérité
après ya florence moncorgé est ce que
dans votre bouquin il ya un mot contre
les chevaux - c'est le juge pourriez
est-ce que vous accepteriez le
raisonnement suivant que je crois que je
fais dans le bouquin qui est dire
il est clair que la justice avait besoin
d'être émancipée et qui avait nécessité
d' une forme d'égalité face à la loi
qu'on a de ce point de vue et je le dis
fait un progrès considérable
ce que je crois c'est qu'il est en train
de se passer en france qui va se passer
en france ce qui s'est passé en italie
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné ce
complexe médiatico judiciaire parce que
là je persiste et je signe même si à
cause de ça il enlève le sur ce jeudi
que ce complexe médiatico judiciaire est
en train d'aller tellement loin qu'à un
moment l'opinion se retourne et que
finalement l'italie est en train de
revenir à l'opacité le biais de que
votre institution est en train de
prendre
c'est que le contre-pouvoir est devenu
pouvoir vous n'étiez rien vous êtes en
fin de rencontre et un voire non non ne
me raconter par sa mère et vous êtes en
train de la meilleure mi en afrique le
président de la république actuel est
passé entre les mailles de la justice il
y avait un vrai pouvoir judiciaire
non ce n'est pas où on en est
aujourd'hui je pense maintenant je vous
laisse conclure parce que vous avez fini
non écoutés d'autres débats étaient plus
nuancées que je croyais c'est à dire que
au fond je pense qu'on a quand même tous
le sentiment que vous croyez qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans les combats que
vous menez mais vous admettez qu'à la
fin il ne faut pas qu'ils aient de
communauté et qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
société de citoyens entre eux tous les
gens qui l'avaient attaqué dans son
bouquin avant de demander un franz
olivier giesbert ce qu'il en pense je
vais libérer notre ami robert smith de
cube cypher match quelque chose commune
merci merci où rachida est ravie je
crois que c'était un des plus grands
moments de sa vie elle a rencontré celui
dont les posteurs orner sa chambre merci
beaucoup
robert
[Musique]
alors france voilà c'était donc
l'adaptation télévision du papier du
point que vous aviez fait sur la sortie
du livre de minc c'est vraiment de la
bonne télé si je peux me permettre
ouais parce qu on en crève en fait je
crois qu on en crève du bourrage de
crâne du politiquement correct de la
pensée unique
alors aujourd'hui il s'est passé quelque
chose dire depuis la publication de
solides effectivement provoqué un vrai
débat je trouve que la pensée unique
un petit peu pris un peu de plomb dans
les reins et c'est une bonne chose parce
que je pense que quand il ya trop de
tabous et c'est le cas souvent dans la
société française dans débat plus or on
doit toujours débattre sur tous les
sujets même s'il arrive au politiquement
correct d'avoir raison merci d'avoir été
avec nous franz olivier giesbert
ils sont noirs mesdames messieurs vivre
dans maintenant messieurs l'heure est
grave
tu sais qu est ce qui va arriver lors de
la [ __ ] comme s'il en pleuvait ouais
si les modèles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
samir m
[Applaudissements]
salut
[Musique]
bonjour témoin
hier
mais madame monsieur
ouais je vais effectivement certains
pourront me dit elle était déjà là il ya
quelques semaines je sais je sais je
sais mais j'ai du mal à ne pas les
inviter je me suis retenu parce que je
vous les invités la semaine d'après
d'ailleurs comment ça va kim ça fait un
moment qu'ils avaient non mais attends
mais laurent oui qu'est ce que tu veux
oui j'ai cette passion pour kim et
d'ailleurs j'ai appris un truc terrible
crime j'ai appris que j'étais pas
tellement célibataires en fait a appris
sa gelée a pris qui voilà donc j'ai
passé une période un petit peu difficile
la religion n'a rien pu pour moi oui
comme quoi vous n'êtes pas complètement
tort parce que c'est retirer si c'est
faux elle dit ça parce que j'imagine que
quand on fait la promotion à la
télévision c'est toujours mieux de dire
qu'on essaie site internet
je sais que ce n'est pas très honnête
mais ça fait fantasmer les gérants
laurent
ouais
[Musique]
là
ces mots vous saviez qu'elle avait un
fiancé et vous l'avez vous avez laissé
dire comme ça qu'il avait senti un
déclic le concept en retard je pense que
kim a voulu un petit peu préserver son
intimité
oui mais non là c'est pas du tout
préserver parce que moi qu'est ce que
j'ai fait je me suis renseigné j'ai fait
une enquête ou peut être parce que je
suis tombé fou amoureux de kim que oui
je suis désolé il m'appelle à 4 heures
du matin à l'orangé excuse moi alors en
parler de kim parce que j'ai appelé
laurent le toit s'était j'ai le talent
qu'elle était occupée elle avait pas l
est pas le regarder d'une fille l eau
comme turckheim
ouais bon ben voilà qu'est ce que je
vous dis ceci dit je le tuerais ce mec
je vais le tuer ce n'est pas un mec qui
rit détente à bord non non ça c'est pas
vrai donc voilà c'est déjà plus
sympathique à dakar comment ça va les
filles ça bien ça va très bien si je les
aide c'est à essaimer prêt à laisser le
préférer à la télé si je peux les avoir
toutes les semaines dans l'émission
voilà on les ateliers dessus
tu te rapproches de ton égal ton idéal
que tout à fait bon enfin heureusement
heureusement l'américain 800 yacine
heureusement il ya ce single qui sort ça
nous donne l'occasion de nous revoir
ah ouais s'appelle somme c'est on va
écouter à quoi ça ressemble un petit peu
puis pendant ce temps là je sais je
ferai mes larmes
[Musique]
m
un somme silence est le nouveau single
des models et je crois pour pouvoir vous
admirer toutes les trois que je vais
vous demander d'aller chanter cette
chanson
m
ce home cell mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
c'est une
rien de moins
[Musique]
c'est aussi
et c'est vrai
m
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]
m
non
tha
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
non non non
je
là
mais
le conte assez merci beaucoup isabelle
somme c'est dingue ou alors je veux un
truc extraordinaire c'est que vous êtes
eric cantona d'une thème si d'élite est
en berne aux femmes que vous n'avez pas
regardé pour pas pour même pas avoir
l'idée de péché je dis pas pêcher mais
avoir l'idée de pêcher j'ai vu ça non je
suis fidèle à mon univers
ah ouais vous étiez dans votre dans
votre univers oui elle vous a plu au
moins un autre chose pourquoi vous
n'avez pas pourquoi je je sais pas je
vais pas du tout je ya de baignade y a
des gens pour ça mais je connais je suis
moi je connais mais ici c'est vraiment
lourd pas le trafic bien sûr mais les
alimenter
juste
alors j'ai remarqué un crime c'est de ce
ce danseur là il vous passez la main
autour de la de la taille j'ai du mal je
suis désolé quand je vois un autre
garçon qui vous touche comme ça ça va
vraiment puis j'ai fait une connerie
parce que j'en ai parlé à ma femme moi
je l'avais dit tu sais j'ai rencontré
une fille sur un plateau tout ça donc
j'étais très très maintenant j'en viens
à douter de tout ah non alors c'est vrai
que tout s'écroule autour d'eux ça a été
terrible
j'en viens à me demander si vous êtes
vraiment vietnamienne finalement fait ça
maintenant on remet tout en question et
maintenant c est ce qu est ce que vous
êtes vraiment l'espagnol vous vous êtes
vraiment noir
moi j'essaye gso et doit gérer dans le
fruit madassamy voit la mairie qui va
lancer avec tim déjà préparé un petit
ballet tous les deux quelle couleur le
ballet un petit balai c'est une très
très bonne idée
alors cet été vous allez être je vous
allez faire là la tournée d'été chez
machine ou est ce qu'on peut vous voir
où est ce que je vais leur d'accord je
ne veux pas des roues que tout le monde
fait un petit peu vous et c'est juste en
face de chez moi
c'est une petite île
petit il vient aussi un certain david
guetta alors tout le monde baisse avec
tout le monde c'est ça le showbiz c'est
comme ça quand j'étais là je vais faire
ça a été terrible à vivre sans savoir
qui sont les menteurs tous les jours on
fait que travailler mon message à nous
de travailler sous froid jamais entendu
c'est sur faut dire que leur manager
s'appelle kuni donc on va pas passer la
journée là dessus merci les models
achats comme image moi c'est délicat
non
attention passe au blind test ce soir un
blindtest spécialement consacrée à
laurent baffie et moi puisqu'il
s'appelle drôle d'oiseau laurent est aux
platines j'appelle ma soeur philippe
corti
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
tout le sommes sûrs
très bien bravo didier le destin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez le passif les filles les
garçons toronto les principes j'imagine
qu'à la comédie française on joue
beaucoup au blind test inchy d'art je
veux l'interprète bien évidemment et
toutes les chansons parle d'oiseaux
vous vous en êtes rendu compte attention
perroquet
[Musique]
ouais cylindrique
malin d'yves jeuland maintenant quand je
vais à bien entendu donc c'est l'équipe
de charlotte de turckheim qui marque un
point bravo jugez plutôt
et
l'équipe 2 qui ne marque pas de points
si c'est pas du tout une vengeance
non pas du tout attention vous allez
trouver celui-là c'est laid mais c'est
rare et encore comme d'habitude assez
d'amis c'est pas jouer au bras une telle
attention pipe ou dommages
non non
beatles beatles ringo
attention ministre koné afp
[Applaudissements]
attention vip les google
si ça me fait dire qu'il devait la star
ses propres actions
joe dassin bah oui un ring au coin
[Applaudissements]
le suspect se dit c'est par gérard
palaprat ça on à eloïse partout de
françois c'est trop fort pour ni donc
voilà oui c'est très très fort
effectivement se réduit aux killed the
video star par ringo le mari de celle à
mesdames et messieurs rapport avec les
oiseaux
ça s'appelle le grand corbeau nous un
coup pareil pour moi attention film
[Musique]
il est
oui
attention et vite
complet
comme un temps c'est énorme comme ils en
ont cinq savamment barras va sherry
thomas oui normal c'est comme ça l'idée
de cette tâche aux mets toi à l'aise et
la tension fip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
gianni schicchi a lieu on n'est pas
manchester un temps marque pas beaucoup
la métare est kadhafi
une énorme affiche alors attention
philippe oeuvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va même si tâche aussi un aythami un
manteau par dessus en plus c'est
beaucoup la wii bon mais c'est très très
bien je t'apprendrai kim a joué au blind
test vous perdrez sauvage rx feu
attention film ajoute jean-paul chose
qui volent
cet oiseau niçois
nous avons affaire à deux mètres du
blind test que sont laurent baffie et
pascal sellem je crois qu'on est sifflé
q3 vous dépassez voûte à trois points
mais quand même c'est très très fort
heureusement bafia le double de toi mais
attention la règle aux autres à la règle
du jeu où il rappelle la philippe les
autres peuvent jouer les hôtes peuvent
jouer comme ça viendra mais aussi parce
que ça veut dire des filles plus facile
sur ce coup là on sait pas si toutes vos
soirées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on la connaissait pas celle là dans son
sang froid elle est pas mal du tout et
quoi elle est pas mal du tout attention
philippe séguin
[Musique]
tête pour ma fille 4 pour l'équipe de
kim tillie personnes il est très fort en
kit changé attention au sida
c'est la vie
passé d'un nom
oui
les faits
[Musique]
l'intention
c'est dans
c'est la vie
incident non
bien oui
c'est qui bon point partout un point
partout méline parce que quoi qu'on
pense john hocking
je me dis que c'est un point partout sur
le toit pour lever le poing qui le
coiffe
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais fait ça on en lit d'un
demi-milliard dix ans mais quand c'est
toi qu'il fait c'est bien c'est moi qui
l'ait fait bon alors là je vous signale
qu'on sort du par équipes on arrive au
chacun pour sa gueule à la c'est très
très dur là très très dur surtout le
premier qui est le banco bien entendu
vous êtes prêts yes je pense que david
guetta peut la connaître celle là
attention pile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à savoir pourquoi je devais connaître ce
que tu fais tu as vraiment pas de quoi
être champion c'est une très belle
chanson qui fait la joie de nombreux
français david attention philippe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que leur indice son nom
et un prénom de fille
[Musique]
doubler mes angoisses 1,28
c'est le mari de
rio de lna philippe halley
[Musique]
le choix
mari d'helena celle d'un trop haut
une journée a été soufflé
barbie par corte non pas moi c'est toi
qui a soufflé ces barbaries c'est dans
le public est vraiment j'ai fait en leur
nom mais si c'est dans le bol de la
basse et très bien le point bas la voilà
le poids
bon je m'en fous même si on est plus par
équipes le point va quand même à lolo
chasse que c'est mon pote voilà c'est
long c'est injuste rêver mais vite juste
marrant tu le sais très bien
attention maintenant le mega man qu il
est question de volatiles une fois de
plus avec notre méga manque au film
[Musique]
le tonnerre aux siens
lyon vient m'aider
ouais
[Musique]
non
il savait combien pour laurent deux bons
laurent laurent baffie pardon
hulot
[Applaudissements]
j'en connais
c'était toujours les sciences
charlotte de turckheim
bd
diagral
darcy
d'état versus david bowie
tiens selon wang et son remix 2011 et
l'album s'appelle comme son tee shirt
sec gmt
en tournée tout l'été et le 8e gazon
comme un chat haibi sa fenêtre chaud
otage a eu ici
tout est là
c'est la white mercier bien sûr
mangeur de thierry binisti
eric cantona rachida brakni
écharpe orange et jocelyn quivrin et ça
sort le 16 juillet robert smith de tours
richesse et dvd qu'isabelle trilogie
franz olivier giesbert travail un peul
giesbert l'abatteur chez gallimard dans
la collection noire les models
les modèles chez zynga
some say voilà rappelle jean rochefort
lost in la mancha de keith futton et
luis pépé avec jean rochefort johnny
depp était
voilà reporter sans frontières l'album
de philip plisson pour la liberté de la
presse
au revoir
j'étais la dernière émission
j'étais la dernière émission de la
saison
tu va pas pleurer pyrénées nord rendre
en septembre
[Applaudissements]
la plaque
je n'ai nous
[Musique]
je ne
vous
[Musique]
je ne
m
[Musique]
je
je n'ai
[Musique]
voilà